tableau is a powerful data visualization
and business intelligence tool that is
widely used to analyze data create
business reports and build interactive
dashboards you can derive meaningful
insights and make business decisions
using tableau
hi guys welcome to this video tutorial
on the tableau crash course
our experienced instructor michelle will
take you through the course and help you
learn tableau from scratch first you
will learn what tableau is and how to
install tableau
then you will understand how to connect
data to tableau explore its different
features and create basic charts and
graphs
next you will learn about the different
types of joins in tableau rank functions
and level of detail or lod
you will get an idea to create tableau
dashboards using world population data
health as well as economic data
finally we will look at some of the
important interview questions that can
help you crack a tableau interview
over to michelle now hello and welcome
to tableau training for beginners my
name is michelle covine and i'm with the
simplylearn team today we'll be talking
about all the things you need to know to
get started with tableau
so here's our agenda we'll be talking
about business intelligence and why it's
important and some bi tools then we'll
talk about tableau and why we use
tableau for business intelligence and do
a quick overview of tableau installation
then we'll show you how you can get
started by connecting to data and we'll
do an overview of the tableau workspace
we'll go a little bit deeper into the
tableau workspace as we look at
worksheets and dashboards and we show
you how you can ask questions using
visualizations we'll look at hierarchy
and drill down calculated fields we'll
look at parameters and sets and finally
we'll show you how to build a donut
chart and a 2d pie chart so what is
business intelligence
companies use business intelligence
technologies to collect analyze and
present data in order to create
actionable information
today's businesses are always seeking
insights about their customers products
and services so businesses are faced
with many questions such as how do i
know my customers are happy what would
make my customers stay and how can i
increase awareness of my products and
services
business intelligence can help you
answer those questions when you have a
question about what your customers are
feeling what your customers are doing
who the customers are and what's the
best channel to target them business
intelligence is a method of transforming
your data into these insights and
measurable metrics business intelligence
tools are designed to make the data flow
manageable in the age of information
tableau is one of many tools to help
manage the data flow and turn data into
actionable information but we also have
click and sap and oracle you may have
heard of some of these let's take a look
at some of the benefits of tableau as
your business intelligence tool so why
would we use tableau it can be connected
to 40 different data sources the more
data sources it can connect to it means
that you are more likely to get direct
access to your data it can build
interactive dashboards with just a few
clicks which can help you quickly
understand your data and it lets you see
your outliers
there's also simple analytics built
right into tableau such as trends and
forecasting that can help you understand
your data on a deeper level
tableau has been a leader in the gartner
magic quadrant for the last six years
and that includes 2018. here we will
take a look at an overview of the
products offered by tableau so we have
tableau desktop which is where you do
all of your development this is where
you connect to and build visualizations
and dashboards today we'll be using
tableau public which is a free version
of tableau desktop but with some
limitations such as having no r
integration and it can only support up
to a million rows of data also any data
published here is made public so you
can't use this for private company
information then there's a new tool
called tableau prep where you can
prepare your data by seeing it visually
before you connect and build reports
there's also tableau online which is a
cloud-hosted version of tableau server a
place where you can publish your
dashboards and it enables you to share
your dashboards in a secure way tableau
server has an option to be on-premises
so let's just do a quick comparison
between building a visualization in
excel and building one in tableau okay
so here we have an excel file full of
data that we will soon connect to and
use for some of our demonstration
purposes
and you can see that we have information
about orders if we wanted to find out
the quantity sold and the sum of sales
for each region we could do that by
creating a pivot table so we'll make it
i selected my cells we'll make it in the
new worksheet
and here we have the beginnings of a
pivot chart and we can grab region and
pull it into our columns
and then we'll grab
sales
and put it into values
and then we also want to look at
quantity and put that into values and
it's automatically summing up sales and
quantity but you can choose if you want
it to be sum or not and then we'll take
our values and put it on rows so that we
can see
sales and quantity one on top of the
other and that's the basics of a pivot
chart now let's do a similar thing in
tableau
okay so we have our connection to the
data and tableau automatically splits
out the dimensions from the measures
we'll go into more depth on that later
but we can come and grab a region and
put it onto columns
and we get a similar thing maybe a
little nicer formatted and then we can
come and put quantity
there
if we want to add sales to it we can
double click on sales and we'll have
quantity and sales one on top of the
other we can put sales on top by
dragging quantity
down in that box we also have this show
me dialog box which allows you to
see what visualizations you could build
using what's already on the screen or
the things that you have selected so
right now we could quickly switch it to
bar charts and now we can see quantity
and sales across our region with bar
charts or we could switch it to stacked
bars
and we can see our quantity across
the regions if you close that we can see
our legend over here and then our sales
across the region
so in tableau we have a lot of really
quick flexibility to turn just text into
a visualization
so in summary we can see a side by side
of what we made using pivot tables in
excel and what we made in a similar
amount of time in tableau let's get
started with the tableau installation as
for requirements you need windows 7 or
later or you need your mac operating
system to be 10.11 or later here are
some of the browsers you can use to
install tableau we will be installing
tableau public today and to do that you
just google tableau public download and
click on that first link and then you
put in your email address and click
download the app so
let's just
look up tableau public download
and it's this first one you can click
download now
it takes you to the tableau public page
where you can click sign in and create
an account free
this gives you a place to save the
visualizations you make but keep in mind
anything you save on tableau public is
public and then you come here and you
enter your email address and click
download the app and it should give you
executable file
that you will download
and once it's downloaded you should be
able to open tableau public so let's go
take a look at the tableau public
opening page
so this is what tableau public looks
like when you first open it on your left
you have the different things you can
connect to
this is more limited in tableau public
than it is in tableau desktop so if you
invest in tableau desktop you have
many many things you can connect to
you can also connect to data by clicking
this drop down connect data piece that's
especially useful when you've already
started your visualization
then we have the central portion called
open this is where anything that you
have opened up previously will show up
you can also click open from tableau
public and when you have
my connections timed out so i need to
log in
but when you log in
it says no workbook found to try
publishing first this is where you'll
see all of your published tableau public
dashboards over here we have discover
and it has some how-to videos
visualization of the day
which is where people who have made
tableau public visualizations get
recognized for their skill and you get
some pretty cool ideas when you look
there
so let's get started by connecting to a
data source we'll click microsoft excel
and we'll choose our excel file and open
it up and this is our data source page
this shows you the sheets on the excel
file and allows you to drag them in so
that you can see the data show up this
gives you a preview of what your data
will look like
you can see the tableau is starting to
classify our fields so anything that has
abc on it
shows that that's a column that has
strings in it we also have a globe which
is where tableau has recognized these
values to be geographical
so we have um state and it's recognized
that it contains states it bases it on
the keywords that it stores to identify
if it's geographical and so it takes a
look and you've named it city and it
knows that city is geographical we also
have the calendar symbol where it's
recognized that it's a date field and we
also have row id that shows up with the
hashtag and it recognizes it's a number
so now that we have our data source
pulled in we can come here and hit sheet
which is where you start to build your
visualization let's take a look at all
the different pieces of this before we
go any further we have the data that
we're connected to up here is our orders
sheet from the sample superstore excel
sheet we have dimensions on top and
measures on bottom these are where we're
going to get the fields to drag and drop
here we have our cards we'll look more
in depth at our cards in a moment and
these are our shelves the column shelf
and the row shelf where you can drag
things in to make changes happen in the
visualization center we have our show me
tabs where you can see we took a brief
look at this earlier but you can see all
the different visualizations you can
build here
a neat thing about show me is that when
you hover
it'll tell you what types of fields you
need to build it so for a symbol map try
one geographical field zero or more
dimensions or zero to two measures and
that's how you can build a geographical
symbol map
and when you're done with show me you
just close it
let's take a look here at our sheets so
we have sheet one and sheet two a sheet
is basically just one visualization at a
time
let's get rid of the extra sheet we have
a dashboard which is where you can pull
multiple sheets on to show multiple
visualizations at one time
and then we have what's called the story
which allows you to show
a sequence of visualizations so that you
can tell a story
perfect okay so we saw that tableau is
categorizing
our different fields
and it is also giving it a role
so we have dimensions on top and
measures on bottom
dimensions contain descriptive values
such as names dates and geographical
data you can use dimensions to reveal
details in your data that is qualitative
details we also have measures which
contain numeric quantitative values that
you can measure measures can be
aggregated and when you drag a measure
onto the view tableau will apply an
aggregation to that measure it's sum by
default
so let's show this by building what we
built before we'll grab region and we'll
see its four distinct
values as a dimension
and then we'll double click on quantity
and we can see the
numbers here the measures and you can
see here that it is the sum of quantity
and now we can also double click on
sales and we can see quantity and sales
to discuss a little bit more about
dimensions and measures you can see that
in general measures are numbers and
dimensions are not but sometimes like
row id it is a number now why would we
have a number up here instead of in the
measures so you can tell the difference
between number whether it should be in
measures or it should be in dimensions
based on whether you'll need to do any
calculations on it or if you would want
to be able to aggregate it at some time
so for
sales
if you have
several orders in a day you might want
to know what the sum of those sales are
but if you have several orders in the
day
and they're on rows 2 3 4 and 5 you
might not want to know the sum of the
rows so tableau is smart enough that
when it sees id it knows that it belongs
up in the dimensions now you can switch
so if row id was actually something you
would want to aggregate for some reason
you can drag it down to the measures and
add it down there
but in our case row id isn't something
that you want to sum or average can you
think of any other numbers that might
not show up as a measure that should be
a dimension comment below with your
answers as we discussed before
dimensions are on top measures are on
bottom and you can see the blue is
associated with dimensions and green is
associated with measures but it's a
little bit more complicated than that so
dimensions are qualitative and measures
are quantitative but blue means we want
our label to be discrete and green means
we want our label to be continuous let's
make a new sheet and make a
visualization to kind of show this so we
can bring on quantity and we're going to
use it as a dimension but you can see
even when it's dimension you can choose
continuous or discrete so right now it's
a dimension but it's green a little bit
different than what you might expect and
then we'll do sales so now we can see
over the different quantities what our
sales was yeah has been for this last
this period of time that we're looking
at i believe it's four years so for when
people bought three items the total
sales was that number and you can see
that this is an axis so it's from 1 to
15. now if we change it from continuous
to discrete you can see that 1 is a
label 2 is a label and it's not an axis
ranging from one to it doesn't even have
15 because there are no values under 15.
these are just individual labels so we
go back it's green again and you can see
that it's an axis so we have two greens
on here so we have two axes and change
it back to discrete and now we have one
axes and one set of individual labels so
let's go back to our sheet three we have
all of these different
sales by the different quantity numbers
and up here we have our sorting when you
hover it tells you what kind of sorting
is going to happen so we could sort
quantity descending by sales so we can
see that when they buy three things we
have the highest sales
you can do the opposite
where it's the lowest
to the highest
number of sales you can also do sorting
more in depth by clicking on the
quantity and right clicking sort so we
could just sort
by
descending or ascending or by sales or
alphabetic
which is
not what we want
you can choose the field or you can
manually change your sorting here
and now we're back to what we had at the
beginning now that we've had an overview
of how tableau works let's go into a
little more detail
tableau is very much built on the
premise of drag and drop
so
let's build a simple visualization
and talk about
what each of these shelves and marks
cards specifically do
so we're going to make a simple chart
which is average sales by region
so we know we want
sales
on
let's do sales on
rows now for rows and for metrics since
this is continuous like we talked about
before it's making an axes
for our sales
we also can drag
region
onto columns and it makes one column per
region so that's how it works with
dimensions if you um
pull a dimension onto columns you're
saying i want one
blank per column i want one region per
column so if you wanted to do it by
instead of region
if you want to remove something from a
visualization you just pull it back off
or you can hit undo or control z
tableau has the benefit of having
unlimited undo's so let's say we wanted
to
bring on city let's say we want one
column per
city and that's what you get and there's
a lot of cities
so that's what it looks like let's take
city back off
i want one column per
region
and for
sales
i want my rose axes
to show me where sales are
great now let's say we want to adjust
the color of these bars you can click on
color
and you can select any of them so let's
pick this nice blue or we can pick an
orange and that's how you can determine
the color
but if you want
something else to determine the color
you can take
region
and drag it onto color and now we have
one color per region
now with measures again since they're
continuous it's going to be more like a
scale
so
if i want them to be
a different color based on sales and i
pull sales onto color it's going to be
darker where there's higher sales and
lighter where there's lower sales so
it's continuous
from light to dark
but for region
it is one color per region so they're
distinct colors it's not continuous
great um
let's say we want to sort this
biggest smallest
and we can look at size here so if we
want to adjust the size manually we can
click on it and drag it
but if we want the size to be based on
something else
you choose a measure for the size so if
we want it to be
wider
based on
sales we will drag sales onto size and
we can see that it gets bigger with
bigger sales we do the same thing
and replace the sales with profit and
now it's bigger if there is bigger
profit and drag that back off so you can
determine manually or you can do it with
your measures
for label let's say we want the sales on
to label now we can see
the exact sales
number
for each
region
what if we wanted the name of the region
there as well we can drag region onto
labels and we can see sales for the west
region
you can adjust which one goes on top
see how we have two t's here those are
both labels
great uh two tip
when we click on tool tip it'll show us
what's going to happen
when we hover so as i hover here on east
it says region east sales and that shows
the sales amount
now we talked about
i'll take my labels back off wanting to
make this visualization not for the sum
of sales but for the average of sales so
we will right click on our sum of sales
here in the rows hover over measure
which right now is sum and change it to
average and we have a different
result here so let's sort again and we
can see that the south
region actually has the highest average
of sales which was not the case for the
sum now let's say we want our sum i mean
our sales to be on the label but look
it's giving us the sum of sales label so
we just do the same thing
and change it to average
now we can see our average on the label
the label has some interesting
options
like you can format this
and we could say maybe we want it to be
all of them to be blue
and that happens right there
you can also choose to only show the
minimum and the maximum
this becomes handy on
a line chart where you don't want all
marks labeled because it gets very messy
but you want the tallest and the
shortest part to be labeled and maybe
you just want the tallest so we'll click
label minimum value and remove that
checkbox and now we just have the
tallest value there
and one card that we haven't used yet is
the filters card so
we could allow people
to look at this
but rem only
certain regions so what we can do is we
can come over to region and right click
on it and click show filter and it will
add it to that filters card and now we
can remove central from the mix and just
look at those ones you see if we remove
south the new highest east
now has the label but if we put it back
in south will have the label again if we
don't want to have these filters
we can pull it off there or if we wanted
to filter out
by country oh we just have united states
so let's not filter by country
but we could pull in
category
and we have these filters by category if
we select them all
they'll all be there
and we click show filter and it will
bring it over here and we can remove our
technology and the south still has the
highest for the other two but if we only
include technology you can see the
difference there
so that's the basics of filters
one another thing that i can mention
here
is that you can change the type of mark
manually so you saw when we pulled on
region and we pulled on sales it
automatically made us a bar chart but we
could change this to be a line chart and
you can see that the color changes
because we told it to based on region if
we pull that off
then it would be a line chart there
you can change it to be a lot of
different type of visualizations here
so when you're not using show me to help
determine your graphs you can choose it
manually right here
okay
now let's
look at
building a scatter plot so scatter plot
is when you have a bunch of shapes and
points on a visualization with two axes
that are both measures
so if we take
sales
and put it on the
y-axis and we take
discount and put it on the x-axis we can
see
our point that represents all of our
data with the sum of sales and the sum
of discount
and if we wanted to see this per
order we'll take order id and put it on
to detail now what detail does is it
determines the level that we are
building our visualization at so
grabbing order id and putting onto
detail
gives us all of these little points so
for each order what was our sales
and what was our discount so we have
out here some outliers that you can find
very quickly
let's actually do product id instead so
i'll put it right over top of order id
and it will replace it
now we see all of our products
anything that has high sales is up here
anything that has high discount is over
here you can see that it sort of has a
trend
where
things with high sales do not have high
discounts which makes sense if we wanted
to
know what
category these products i'll show up in
we could take category
and put it onto shape
and now we have three different shapes
that tell us the categories
tableau has a cool new highlight feature
which allows you to show
just the dimension that you want to see
but it leaves the other ones in place so
for example if we click on furniture
first we have to turn on the highlight
feature and then click on furniture
and now you can see all of the furniture
items popping up in our visualization
and how they're kind of clustered in
this area and the pattern for them when
we click on technology
we can see their pattern which is a
little bit different so we have them by
shape
with category let's drag category onto
color as well if you remember category
will determine the color
and the shape at this point and so we
can kind of see the patterns happening
there
so if we want to see our high discounted
items
they're all over here and most of the
things that are getting
high discounts are office supplies which
is interesting
and then our highest sales product up
here now we could take that product id
and find out what that product actually
is out of our oh look we have product
name let's replace product id with
product name
and we see that that is a canon image
class advanced copier
so this copier is our big sales person
and office supplies binders do not give
us very many sales and we're highly
discounting them
so now you know a little bit more about
the details card and the shapes card and
about using highlighting
tableau
so
let's say
we wanted to know by subcategory what
our profit is like
we could grab
subcategory and pull it onto columns and
we would say we want one column per
subcategory
and then let's grab profit
and pull it onto rows
and you can quickly see
which categories
are profitable and which ones are not so
we can also take profit and put it onto
color
so that you can see that even more
clearly
right now it is going from orange to
blue which is tableau's default if we
wanted to change
from what color to what color it was
going we have a lot of options in here
when you go to edit colors
so maybe you wanted to go from red to
blue
just to emphasize that the profit that's
negative is bad so we can hit apply and
now we can see red to blue we have our
categories here
our subcategories here but let's
separate it out by category so what i'm
going to do i'm going to take
subcategory off
i'm going to put on category and that's
my category and then i'm going to put
subcategory on after it so when we put
it in order like this the order matters
in tableau so first it breaks it up by
category and then inside of that it
breaks it up by subcategory
so furniture's all here and then there's
our subcategories under furniture if we
were to move subcategory to the front
it really doesn't group it appropriately
because first it's breaking it up by
sub-category and then by category and
that's not effective we end up with
furniture furniture furniture furniture
spread out across our visualization so
again let's put category to the front
and now we have our profit by category
by sub category
and we can
click
sort subcategory descending by profit
and now what it does is within the
highest group within each group
it then sorts it by profit so you can
tell it's not going to break this group
apart to move tables to the very end
it's going to keep tables inside of
furniture and then it doesn't move
furniture to the very end either
so
what we have here
is a quick view by category by
subcategory how we're doing on profit we
can see that tables is our biggest drain
on profit and so if we wanted to improve
the profitability of furniture
maybe we would
not sell tables anymore it's just not
working out for us
another thing about this visualization
that we could do to improve it
is you can see that there's some of
these words are getting cut off so
we can right click on this axis and
click
rotate label and now you can read the
whole word and so that's helpful also up
here we have our title which right now
is the same name as our sheet
so if we rename the sheet to
profit by
sub category
then it names the title up here so this
is making it look a little bit better
and then here we have profit
and it shows it but without any like
dollar signs so let's come up here to
profit
and click format and you can see that we
can format the sum of profit
to be currency
and
we can do it currency by the thousands
now we can get rid of these decimal
places and now you can see it's just a
little bit nicer a little bit more clear
maybe we don't have to have the label
here that says
category subcategory so we can hide
field labels for columns
because it's pretty clear that these are
categories and these are subcategories
so those are some formatting tips for
you formatting in tableau
is one of those things where there are
just a lot of different ways you could
change things
so in more in-depth videos especially
from simply learn you'll learn more and
more about this
also as we are
building these visualizations if you
want to
have access to this data set so that you
can build along with me just make a
comment in the comments below and the
simply learn team will send you this
data set now we're going to take a look
at creating a hierarchy in tableau
so we'll make a new tab
and we're going to make a sheet
called
sales
by product
and so we will be looking at
sales as a number
and let's bring on product name
now there are a lot of products names so
it's going to make sure that you really
want to do this i'm going to click add
all members and now we can see all of
our products and their sales
overall time
so if we sort this we can see our
highest sale selling item which we
discovered earlier as the advanced
copier and we scroll down to the bottom
our lowest selling items
so we have our products and we can group
that by sub category
and you can see i need to put it in the
front again
and by category
all right i'm going to take product name
back off and we're going to talk about
hierarchies so a product rolls up into a
sub category which rolls up into a
category you can create a hierarchy by
let's start with subcategory and
dragging it onto category and it's going
to create a hierarchy we'll call it our
product
hierarchy
and now it knows that category is the
parent to subcategory
let's do the same thing by grabbing
the product name and putting it
underneath subcategory so now it knows
categories the parent then there's
subcategory and then there's product
name this allows you to instead of
pulling this off or putting it back on
you can bring category on and then you
can expand it by pressing this plus
button and now we see but here's our
sales by category by sub category
and then here's our sales by category by
subcategory by product name this is
really useful when you're creating a
details section for your users
and so when somebody wants to know
let's say you have
show filter for category and a filter
for subcategory
show filter for subcategory and they're
looking at category here and they're
just like i see technology has the
highest sales and i just want to see
technology so i'm going to unclick
furniture and office supplies
let's put category on top and then so i
just have technology will i want to see
what has the highest sales inside of
technology and let's sort it
phones phones does so i just actually
want to look at phones so i'm going to
remove accessories copiers and machines
and what has the highest sales inside of
phones
and sort it and now i can see quickly
the detailed information
without having to change my
visualization let's give this
visualization a little more depth
first i'll add back in all of our
categories and subcategories
by showing across region
so we know technology had the highest
but how does it look across region now
part of the point of tableau is to allow
the users to read the visualizations
very quickly and when you have big
blocks of text like this it's kind of
hard to see which one has the highest
because it doesn't quite stand out very
quickly
so what we can do
is take
sales and drag it onto color
let's change our marks to a square and
now it's going to color each of these it
colors every one of these cells based on
its darkness for sales this is a little
bit heavy of a color you can click color
here and change the opacity to give it a
little bit
of a lighter look
just makes it a little bit see-through
great so now it's a lot easier to see
that the west seems to have the highest
sales
and that technology in the east is the
very highest so now when we
drill into subcategory it keeps that
coloring and we can see more in depth
and quicker that phones has the highest
across most of them it's not quite the
highest in the west because chairs is
the highest in the west there is one
place in tableau where hierarchies are
built in and that's in dates so dates in
tableau can be very complex because they
allow
very complex visualizations so we will
not go into depth about dates at this
time but let's take a look at how they
work for hierarchies so we have order
date that we can pull onto columns here
and you can see that it's blue meaning
that it's discrete so each one of these
is a header instead of it being an axis
across the top
now let's drag
profit
onto rows
so now we can see our profit
over time for each of these years
and tableau has some hierarchies built
into dates already so when i click this
plus on
columns it'll split it out into quarters
so this is a header and these are all
sub headers underneath that header
because it is distinct um and discrete
right now instead of continuous so it's
split out year year year year and
quarters quarters quarters quarters this
allows you to quickly compare quarter
one across all of the years and quarter
two across all the years and quarter
four across all the years
another way you could add some more
detail to this is by taking maybe
category and pulling out a color and now
we have one line for each category and
we can see that a drop in technology
is a big part of the responsibility for
that drop we were seeing in quarter two
of 2016. so let's take that back off and
let's take quarter back off
and let's explore continuous dates so
here in dates we have our top section of
dates and then you see it repeats and we
have the bottom section of dates so
we've got year but we also have year
here quarter and quarter now the top
ones are all discrete and when i change
it to a bottom one
year same thing same here it changes it
to be green and now it's continuous
so now instead of this being a header
for 2013 and a header for 2014 it's an
axis so the difference here is when i
press the plus and then changes it to
quarter instead of adding quarter to
year now it's doing quarter four each
year and making one continuous line and
we can keep going and drill down to
month
you can go pretty far
now when we add category as color
we get our three lines for the three
categories and we also have highlighting
turned on here still so when we click on
technology we can highlight technology
with the others in the background so we
don't lose the context of the other
categories
let's take that back off next let us
talk about calculated fields so we'll
make a new sheet and we're going to
create our first calculated field we can
create a calculated field by clicking
this arrow which gives us some options
and clicking create calculated field or
we can come and click in the white space
below dimensions or below measures and
we right click and click create
calculated field let's name it
profit ratio so this is for if we wanted
to create a visualization that showed
the profit ratio but we don't have that
measure readily available to us to bring
in fields for our calculation you can do
it in one of two ways one is to start
typing it
and it will start auto prompting you for
the different measures or for different
calculations or
values you can use or you can come and
drag it in so if we want profit and we
want sales if we do profit divided by
sales that is
a profit ratio
unaggregated
okay and let's make a second calculated
field we could come here and click
duplicate
and that will duplicate our field but i
just want to start over again so i'll
click create calculated field
and i will call it profit
ratio
aggregated
and in this one we're going to do sum
click
of profit
click divided by
sum of sales
okay so now what's the difference
between profit ratio
aggregated and profit ratio on
aggregated how will those behave
differently in tableau let's look at
this by looking at a single
order
so first let's bring on all the orders
and all the products
under that order and let's look at this
order
so
i want to filter this whole dashboard to
only this order so i can right click on
it and click keep only that creates a
filter up here
that only has that box checked
and if i want to get rid of this later
i can just pull it right off of filters
and everything will come back but i want
it so keep only
and now let's take a look at profit
ratio aggregated i double clicked on it
and i added it here and profit ratio
unaggregated again double clicking and
now they're side by side let's give us a
little bit more room
so when i dragged that out it gave us
more room so we could see them side by
side and the entire titles okay so i
chose to look at one order and these
product names because the combination of
order and product name is unique one per
row we know that tableau will aggregate
the data up to the lowest level in the
visualization and i brought it all the
way down to the lowest level of the data
source so we have no aggregation right
now
so when we're looking at it without any
aggregation these two calculations are
the same profit ratio aggregated let's
look at that again we'll click edit and
that's the one where we sum profit and
some sales before we divide
and then we've got profit ratio
unaggregated so let's also look at
profit and look at sales this is a
technique that i use when i'm trying to
understand how my calculated fields are
working try to break it down to the
lowest level possible and see if it's
doing what i expect
so we've got profit and we've got sales
now both of them are at
point five or fifty percent and that's
because profit is eight and sales six
sixteen for adam's telephone messaging
now
let's take off product name
when we take off product name we can see
that they start to vary we've got profit
ratio aggregated and profit ratio
unaggregated so here we have profit and
sales the profit ratio should be profit
divided by sales so let's open up a
calculator
and make it a little smaller
so if we take profit at
219.1 and divide it by sales at 508.6
we get
0.4 not 1.8 so where does this 1.8 come
from
well let's put product name back on here
what happens is with profit ratio
aggregated it sums up the profit and
then divides it by the sum of sales so
that's what we did when we took off
profit ratio and aggregated we had the
sum of profit and divided it by the sum
of sales which is what we want profit
ratio unaggregated however does the
calculation profit divided by sales and
then
sums it afterwards you can see it right
here it's the sum of profit ratio on
aggregated so it makes this calculation
and then
it adds up 0.5 plus 0.5 plus 0.3 plus
0.5
and that's where we get our 1.8 which is
what we see
when we pull off product name 1.8 so for
most calculations you want to do profit
ratio aggregated
where you determine how it's aggregated
before you do the calculation
so let's remove profit ratio on
aggregated
and delete it let's go to profit ratio
aggregated
and just call it profit ratio
perfect now we no longer need anything
that we have on our visualization right
now so let me show you a quick trick to
clear the board tableau has this button
up here which is called clear sheet you
can also do on windows alt shift
backspace and you just click clear sheet
and it will start you over with that
sheet and that really helps when you've
dragged a bunch of things on and really
made a mess when you're trying things
out okay so we're going to build a
visualization and we're going to look at
region and we're going to look at it by
profit ratio and so now we have this bar
chart by profit ratio let's color this
by region we can also pull on profit and
sales and we can see all three of them
side by side split out by region
now let's say we also wanted to see
each region
by sales per customer so let's create
some calculated fields that will help us
do that let's create our first
calculated field
that's going to get us a count of
customers
let's call it total
number of customers
and so we have customer name and
customer id let's do
count distinct
of customer id and that gives us the
total number of customers
apply so right now we could take total
number of customers and see which
categories have the highest number of
customers perfect but that's just one
part of our calculation we want to see
total sales divided by total number of
customers so let's make our second
calculated field and we're going to call
it
sales per
customer
we're going to do our sum
of sales which we can drag in
and divide that by
total number of customers now you see
that calculated field we just made pops
up inside of our calculation
dialog box and we hit apply
and it shows up so we hit ok and let's
replace
total number of customers
with
sales per customer and now we can see
our sales per customer ratio and which
ones have the highest or for this next
part i'm going to make a couple of
visualizations in a row that all applied
to the same information using a couple
of different tactics so
first let's use show me so i want to
look at
region and sales for this visualization
so i'm going to control click
region
after i clicked sales so one more time
i'm going to
click on sales and i'm going to control
click region
and i'm going to click show me and it's
going to give me all of the different
visualizations i could make with region
and sales let's pick
tree map
great so now we have a tree map that
shows us our sales
by region
and we have the size and the color of
the box is both sales so let's say we
wanted the size to be sales but the
color to be profit so let's grab profit
and drag that on to sales so now we can
see our most profitable to our least
profitable let's
edit our colors and we're going to
change it from red to blue diverging red
to blue but let's go to advanced and
make the center number zero
this means that it will never be red
unless it's less than zero so let's hit
apply so it's all blue and if anything
ever goes negative then it will be red
okay let's call this sheet
sales
profit by region
perfect
now we're going to start using our
geographical
fields so we have state city country and
postal code let's double click on state
and see what happens
awesome so it is
generated these two fields tableau has
generated longitude and latitude for us
and it's been able to recognize the
states in the united states and where
they're located and given it a longitude
and latitude
so next we will
look at sales
by state by double clicking on sales and
what it's done was change the size of
the dot based on sales now i think i'm
going to move sales from size to color
and it has automatically changed it to a
filled map instead of dots on a map
perfect so now we can see the states
with the
biggest amount of sales let's put it
back onto size and we have our circles
again
let's put sales on the size not stayed
on to size and we have our circles again
but let's make them a little bit bigger
these two marks on the tableau size line
are to give you an idea of how big and
how small you should go before it gets
too difficult to see so when we go
bigger than the bigger line it detects
that you're getting close to having
overlap
but it's up to you as the builder okay
so we have size for
sales again and for profit onto color
again so you can see
anything that is more profitable is
darker and anything that is less
profitable
or less than zero in this case is orange
let's do what we did with color before
change it to
red blue diverging and set our center
point to zero okay so now we know that
if anything is red it was negative in
profit perfect let's name this sheet
sales
profit
by state
great now let's look at sales and profit
by category so we have category and
we've made columns so this is when we
drag something to the columns shelf just
remember we want one column per category
and let's double click on sales and it's
going to put it into text and that's not
what i want so let's take sales and drag
it onto rows and it automatically makes
a bar chart so now we have one bar with
the axis of sales for furniture office
supplies and technology
now let's
take profit and also put it on
rows so now we have two bar charts one
for sales and one for profit we can
change which one is a bar and which one
is maybe a bubble chart
by clicking on its appropriate marks
card so if we want to change them both
we can click on all and change them both
to maybe circles and you can see how
they go up and down
but if we want to just change
one of them let's put those back to
automatic we'll go to profit and change
that one to
the circles so now we can see
those profit numbers and if we want them
to be overlaid on the same area
we would right click on profit the
second measure on the rows and click
dual axis so now let's put them onto the
same axis you can see that their axes
are not lined up let's go to sales and
change it back to
a bar
so now we have two charts occupying the
same space
one of them is a bar chart and one of
them is a bubble chart and we can see
our sales versus our profit at least
they're not the same amount of dollars
obviously but we can see a higher
sales and a higher profit we also have
medium sales and a medium profit we have
a medium sales but a really low profit
and it's interesting to see that
contrast so let's rename this sheet
as
sales
profit
by category
and
finally we're going to make our details
sheet so we're going to go down to
subcategory level and bring it onto rows
and remember subcategory can expand out
to the actual products let's bring that
back in and we're going to bring sales
onto columns which makes this a sales
bar chart and profit onto columns which
makes us a profit bar chart now let's
color them by their appropriate
individual color so we'll go to the
sales marks card and drag sales onto
color
now sales is colored by sales we'll do
the same thing here we did before we'll
go red blue diverging
[Music]
and make the center
zero we actually don't have to do that
for sales because sales will never be
negative but it's pretty important for
profit so we'll go to the profit marks
card and take profit onto color
and do the same thing there
we have
red blue diverging
advanced center is zero great
so now if it's negative it will be there
so let's sort this
by profit and so both of them have
sorted with profit in mind and we can
easily see our subcategories that have a
negative profit
rename this
and we'll call it our details sheet
so now we have these four visualizations
that all have to do with similar
information
i think i want these bigger on the
states so we'll just keep making that
bigger perfect now we're going to make
our first dashboard so for our dashboard
we have
information over here that shows you
what sheets you can bring on these get a
little bit more complex so they'll be
covered in more in-depth type of videos
and then we have our size so
we could make a range of sizes based on
um maybe what you're viewing this on but
we're just going to change it to a fixed
size
and we're going to make it
1400
by
a thousand and this is our
dashboard size so let's bring on sales
profit by region
sales and profit by state now a map
needs a little bit more horizontal space
than region does let's bring sales and
profit by category underneath the region
and the detail underneath the state give
our map more space again perfect
now tableau has this neat feature called
uses filter so you can click use this
filter here and now if i click on any of
these it will filter the other
dashboards based on these features so if
i just want to look at the south and i
click on south it zooms into all my
south states now my categories have
updated to be just the south ones and my
details have updated as well so
we could see that central
has pretty big sales you know bigger
than the south but the profit is lower
than the salve so we can click on
central and focus on central
let's use
that uses filter
on all three of these
dashboards that lead us up to the detail
so building a quick dashboard like this
let's make this taller would allow you
to do some sort of analysis such as
let's take a look at central because
they have relatively high profits but
low sales so we click on central and
then we see oh man texas is having a
really hard time so let's click on texas
and now we're seeing in texas that we
have
negative profit in these categories so
we can control click on furniture and
office supplies and we can see all of
our products that are really just
killing us in texas all of our
subcategories and if we want to go
deeper into products we'll just click
that plus sign and now we see all the
products and we'll sort again
and we can see all the products by
subcategory that are really just killing
us
and are maybe not worthwhile to make
anymore so we're gonna have to
reconsider making the 3.6 cubic foot
counter height office refrigerator at
least for texas it's not very helpful
there and then when you
back out of that subcategory section you
can also
click
somewhere neutral in the dashboard or
click on each thing that you had
selected to unselect it and go back to
the main part of your visualization and
start it all over again now let's move
on and take a look on how to create
parameters and sets so new sheet
and let's make a quick visualization
that will apply our parameters and our
sets too
so let's take a look at all of our
customers
by their sales and let's sort customer
name descending by sales great so now
we're going to make a parameter that
will allow the user of the dashboard to
choose how many customers they want to
see how many of our top customers that
they want to see
so let's click this down arrow and click
create parameter
and we will name it
top and customers
great we're going to make it an integer
and we're going to give them the option
to choose the number of customers within
a range our low is going to be 5 so
we'll let them see 5
or up to 20
and we're going to let them skip with
step size of 5. let's start their
current value right in the middle with
10.
okay so now if you want to see how this
parameter looks you can come down to
parameters before we only had dimensions
and measures on the left side of our
tableau workspace but now we have
parameters that has appeared once we
create a parameter we can right click on
that parameter and click show parameter
control and we can see our top end
customers right now our parameter
control isn't built into any of our
visualizations but you can see how it
works we allow them to go down to five
and up to
20 with steps of 5.
great now we're going to create a set a
set is a custom field that defines a
subset of data based on some conditions
so the set we're going to build is going
to be based on customer name so when you
right click on customer name you can
come down and click create hover on
create and create a set with so far when
we created a parameter and a calculated
field you clicked here
with this down arrow and you saw create
calculated field and create parameter
but it's not there a set has to be based
on an existing field so you come and you
click on the field you want it to be
based on and then hover on create and
you see set
so here's how we can create a set let's
name it
top and
customers
by sales so we're going to allow them to
select the top end customers and have
that select our top customers by sales
so we want this set to include anything
that is in the top however many they
defined by the parameter
by sales so you can come over here to
top
and change it to by field we want it to
be top but not just top static 10 we're
going to click here and our parameter
shows up so it's going to be top top end
customers
and then you can choose
another field here
for it to be defined by and it's sales
and we want it to be by sum of sales
if we wanted it to be by
the average profit we can come here and
click profit and change this to average
and now we would see our top end
customers buy average profit
but we want sales and some
okay so we've created our set and we can
drag it on to rows to see how it works
and we can see these are our top 10
customers by their sales and we have
this in slash out
that's generated by our set so if we
take our set
first let's see how this line moves when
we change our number here so right now
it's 10. when we move it up we see our
line moves down to include the top 15
and now we can quickly see our top 20.
we'll go back to 10
and let's grab the set and drag it onto
our filters so now we have filtered the
data down to our top 10. if this were
applied to a dashboard this would allow
the end user to see the top 10 quickly
and then maybe expand it out to the top
20 if they're interested in that
information now let's move on to
creating a donut chart so a donut chart
is basically a pie chart with a white
center so let's start by building a pie
chart which in tableau is pretty easy
especially if you use show me so let's
create a pie chart for each category
by sales so you're going to click
category and then we're going to control
click sales so we have them both
selected we'll come over to show me and
click
pie and there we have our pie chart
we'll close show me let's come up here
and click entire view so we see our pie
very clearly here if we wanted to have
one pi for each
region we can take region and drag that
onto columns so we have one column for
each region and then one pi for each of
them you can see that the pie varies in
size based on sales as well as the angle
is for sales so east has more sales in
general than south
and this helps you to see that
technology
has smaller sales in the south than it
does in the east so i recommend keeping
if you're going to make pie charts
allowing the size of the pie chart to be
affected as well as the angle by
whatever measure you're using but for
our purposes for donut charts we're
going to want them to all be the same
size so we took sales off of
size and now we have all of our pie
charts the same size now we're going to
make what's called a dual access chart
and to make a dual axis chart we have to
have two axes so let's grab
number of records and we'll grab it and
drag it to rows and we will change it
from sum to minimum and that's because
every record
will have a minimum number of rows of
one and then they all end up on the same
axis great and now we're going to make a
second number of records by minimum and
we can do that by doing those steps
again by dragging number of records up
here and changing it to minimum again
or a quick trick that i can show you is
if you want to
duplicate anything you have on the chart
here you can just hit control and then
click and drag it and it will duplicate
it so if you wanted your number of
records to also be down here onto your
details or on your labels you can
control click it and then leave it there
great so now we have our two axes
and we have our two marks cards that
each affect their own
set of visualizations so let's go to
this top one affects these so let's show
that by changing the size
and it's made these bigger and this
bottom one affects these and we'll do
that by changing it to
circle so now each of these are a circle
let's take category off of color and we
can take some of sales off of detail and
let's change the color to white
and now we're going to put this white
circle on top of our pie chart by
clicking here on our second measure
and clicking dual axis and now it's got
them lined up one on top of the other
and we have our doughnut chart so if we
want our donut
slices to be a little thinner we can
change the size of our inner circle and
make it bigger
perfect and so now we have one pie chart
for each region one donut chart for each
region and if we wanted to take
this header and put it inside of our pie
chart what we can do is take region and
put it on the label for the circle and
it's putting it down here you can come
and edit that by clicking on label and
changing its alignment so let's put it
in the middle
perfect so now we can see
our header here so we don't need it down
here anymore you can right click and
click
show header and it hides that header we
also don't want to see our labels for
our axes so we right click and click
show header there and now we just see
our pies
so to get how the number of sales here
for each of them let's go to
remember our pie marks card and let's
take
our sales and add it to label so now
each of our slices of pie
can tell you how much sales they have if
you take the sales here that's on label
right click and click format we can
change that to currency
and let's get rid of our decimal places
perfect now close formatting and let's
say we want the total
amount of sales to be in the middle here
with central so we go back to affecting
our circle grab sales drag it to label
so now we have four doughnut charts
formatted to allow us to quickly see the
sales numbers
for each segment and also for the donut
as a whole you can also change the
colors that tableau selects for each
slice by coming to the marks card that
has color for the pie so category color
and clicking edit colors and you could
change it to
any of these automatic ones
where if you double click on one it
gives you all of the options for colors
that you could possibly want there's
also several different palettes you
could choose from so let's say we like
this one and you can just click assign
palette and it will grab those off of
there those look very similar to what we
have already so i'm going to pick a
different one
and click assign palette click apply
and this allows you to make some color
changes you can fit your business a
little bit more
specifically
perfect let's say
we make our pies bigger
crease that size
and we'll also increase the center size
oh not that much perfect
now we'll use a similar technique to
create the two-dimensional pie chart
a two-dimensional pie chart can be used
so that you can show
two pie charts at the same time
or a pie chart that's kind of split up
by different categories this has been
available in some other tools and
tableau can do it too so let's just
demonstrate that we're going to start
again by creating our
generic category by sales so we'll
control click sales we come over to show
me and click pie and it makes our pie
for us it remembers the colors that you
have determined in other pages so that's
a nice feature again let's make it
entire view so we can see our pie nice
and big and now we're going to
create our dual axis again so we grab
number of records put it on rows and see
how it adds an axis but each one of
these categories has a different value
for the number of records however they
have the same minimum
value for number of records and it puts
them all right back onto the same spot
great and then we will control click and
drag to make our two axes
let's come to our top one
and make it bigger
that affected both of them because we
still have sales on size
for both of them
so sales is affecting the size of the
pie chart as well as the size of the
angles so let's take sales off of size
for both of them
and make the second pie chart a little
smaller perfect now let's also affect
our second pie chart by having the color
defined by region instead of defined by
sales let's talk about how i'm replacing
it with region so you could change the
color by dragging region onto color and
that replaces it or let's go back and we
can drag region right on top of the
thing we're trying to replace and it
will replace it there
great so now we have the smaller circle
that's going to go on top split up by
region with the angle defined by sales
and the category is on the top one with
the angle defined by sales let's pick
some nicer colors
maybe we'll use the same palette we used
for
category
this one this one seems right but we'll
pick different ones than those three so
we click on the one we want to change
and click on the color we want to change
it to i'm just going to keep following
this write down
apply great and then we
put it on top of the other one by
clicking dual axes now sometimes it's
easier to see these when they have a
border so we can come to color we click
border and add maybe some black lines
it's allow you to see the inner pie
separate from the outer pie
maybe
our border could have white lines how
does that look
and we can make them both bigger
like we did before
well not that big
and you can also add labels like we did
before
we'll take sales onto our labels here
and you can see that hovering allows you
to see all the information you need now
one more thing
so while we like to hide
this axis
we'd also like to maybe hide this grid
line that's occurring so you can click
right click and format and let's go to
our lines
that change that zero line to none
perfect get rid of some of the clutter
on this visualization i still feel like
this outer pie should be a little bigger
and we want to clean up our tool tip so
it doesn't have min number of records in
it this piece should be 100 behind the
scenes so we can come tool tip right as
you click on it it'll pop up with
everything that's in your tool tip and
we're just going to erase
min number of records i erased too much
you need to leave your angle brackets
okay and now this piece of the pie no
longer has that the inner one let's do
that there too
min number of records remove that right
out
and there you have it a two-dimensional
pie chart and here are our donut charts
this demonstration goes to show you that
even when tableau doesn't have
visualization you're looking for in
their basic show me options you can
still get to it so donut charts aren't
included up here and neither is a
two-dimensional pie chart but without
too much extra work we can make it
happen these visualizations are a little
bit more complex than your everyday
visualizations and so i recommend going
through this tutorial with the data set
and following along if you want access
to the data set just comment below and
the simply learned team will get back to
you also comment below with any
questions you have
at this point in the presentation we're
going to put together some dashboards so
first let's build our worksheets for
this dashboard we're going to build a
worksheet called
sales by
year which adds the name up here and
we're going to
take our order date and drag it onto
columns and now we want this to be a
continuous axis so we're going to change
it to our continuous year and now we
have an axis and we're going to look at
sales
so now we have our sales by year if we
want labels on each of these dots we can
drag sales onto
labels and if we want to have different
color lines for each region for example
we can drag region onto color
and that splits our lines up
into the different regions and gives us
a legend over here perfect now we're
going to duplicate this sheet by right
clicking down here and clicking
duplicate now we have sales by year two
let's rename it to
profit
by year
and then let's drag profit right over
top of sum of sales
so that it replaces it with profit now
it's been replaced with profit and all
these different data points are here
however it's still showing the title of
some of sales and that can be very
confusing so always make sure that your
labels are consistent with your data so
let's take profit and drag it over top
of the type labels as well that's more
consistent with our axis
so now we have sales by year and we have
profit by year
let's do a couple of things to clean
these up
like
right click here
go format and we'll change our numbers
to
currency
custom
and now it's marked as dollars
one thing you can do in tableau is let's
undo that
since sales is going to be dollars
pretty much everywhere we use it we can
define our default property for these
numbers so when we right click on the
measure here you can go to default
properties and you have the options to
change the defaults for any of these
things and we're going to change our
number format
change it to
currency custom
no decimal places hit ok and that also
has updated this sheet now that only
works on places where you haven't
specifically defined it to be formatted
differently so we could still define it
to be different here on this sheet than
it is on any other sheet
let's do the same thing for profit
change our default properties
to
the same thing great now let's build our
dashboard
we're going to call this our
overall dashboard
change our
size
this size is a personal preference of
mine i think it fits nicely
on the laptops that i use and that is
used by most of our customers now let's
drag sales by year now watch what
happens when i drag it on here it brings
sales by year but it also brings the
legend
for the region that was created the same
thing should happen with profit by year
it's detected that the same legend is
being used so it didn't bring over a
second legend and we have highlighting
turned on let's see if this works for
both charts we click on central and you
see it highlights central in both charts
that's great so now we have a dashboard
showing us profit by year and sales by
year but let's say we want to be able to
filter this dashboard to just maybe one
category so let's go back to our sales
by year sheet
and let's drag category
onto filters
and now it's going to let us select
we're going to select all
and hit ok and then right click on
category and click show filter so now it
is over here
and we're going to do
a similar thing on profit by year but
we'll do the shortcut where you come
over here to category you right click on
it and you just click show filter and it
puts it here and it puts it here
so now we have
a filter here for category
and a filter here for category
and so when we go to overall
we can come to our
drop down here more options
hover over filters
and you can see category now here's an
interesting thing that we'll see
even though we have a category filter on
both charts when i take furniture out
you can see only sales by year changed
and profit by year stayed the same now
why would that be
that's because we have two different
filters for category one on the sales
worksheet and one on the profit by year
worksheet i'll show that
by clicking here
going to filters
and grab category now we have category
that will affect
profit by year and not sales by year
that's not what we want we want one
filter to affect them both so
let's back it up a bit
take these back off let's go to profit
by year now we're going to take off
category
let's go to sales by year and we're
going to say we want this same filter to
affect both worksheets so we're going to
right click here hover over apply to
worksheets and click selected worksheets
now we select sales by year is selected
and we select profit by year okay so
when we go to
the profit by year
sheet
you can see that it now has category on
there let's go to overall let's come
here
filters category and now we have a
filter
that affects both worksheets
there we go let's format this filter a
little bit we'll come to more options
and we're going to select we want them
to be able to select multiple values
still but let's do it in a drop down
so now
you still have those options
but it is a little bit more compact
let's do
a couple more filters so we can do by
category
let them filter out regions
let's do it the the shorter way right
click
show filter there it is apply to
worksheets
selected worksheets
both of these
okay
dashboard
filters and by region
multiple values drop down
and let's let them
change their
time selection so this one's a little
bit different since we've already
determined that we wanted year and we
wanted it to be continuous filters for
continuous
fields are a little bit different than
filters for
these discrete fields and that's because
continuous fields are a range instead of
just a list so we don't list out a
continuous field we make a range for it
so we've already defined that we want it
to be continuous year and if i come over
here
and click on right click order date and
click show filter it's doing discrete
year by default
so
remove filter if you drag order date
onto filters
it lets you pick what you want it to
look at
let's come up here to year that's
already marked as continuous and click
show filter and now it is year but it's
based on a range and we have this slider
and you can see how that slider affects
our visualization
let me show you a trick to make this
apply to both not a trick but just if
you have not applied it to both
worksheets but you already added it to
the visualization see it's here but it's
only affecting one worksheet you can
change the worksheets
settings right on the filter instead of
having to go to
the worksheet where the filter exists
and it will only give you the options of
the worksheets that are on the dashboard
so there we have it
now it affects both and now we have our
overall dashboard
now let's say you want to be able to see
the total sales on this chart as well as
the sales split up by
each of the regions we can do that as
well so let's go back to our sales sheet
as a quick tip you can go to the sheet
by clicking this go to sheet button here
or here
in the event that you want to go to a
sheet but you don't want to scroll back
and forth to find where it is so go to
sheet now we're going to do a dual
access chart again like we showed
earlier and i'm going to control
click and drag
so now we have some of sales twice
this marks card affects the top one so
we can see that by if i change the
opacity
how it changes the color right here this
is the top one
and this marks card is the bottom one
and we're going to remove region
off of color and that makes our combined
one line again perfect now if we want
this to be on the same space as this we
right click here the second measure in
the rows section and click dual axis
so let's put it right on top i can see
this versus this now if we wanted to on
hover show that this is overall sales we
can click on tool tip region is missing
because we don't have it with the color
by region anymore so we'll erase that
and put
oh we don't want it to be orange let's
make it black
overall sales okay so when you hover
here it says overall sales so we can see
the difference easily let's make it um a
little bit more of a color that'll stand
out just a little darker than the others
perhaps
so when we go back to our work or our
dashboard we can see sales and we can
see our overall sales let's do the same
thing for profit by year
go to sheet
and
control
drag
release
we'll go to our marks card for this
second sheet and pull off region
make it darker
change our tool tip
not orange
overall
profit
okay
and right click
dual axis
there we go now i forgot to do one thing
on the last dashboard when you make a
dual access dashboard it doesn't
necessarily
um sync up these axes and so this axis
over here is for the overall line and
this axis over here is for the region
line
so if we want it to stay that way we
should
edit our axes and instead of calling it
just profit over here
we'll change it to overall profit
and over here
profit
by region
just so that it's clear which axis goes
to the which one
or
you can come here and click synchronize
axes so it's very clear that this is
much bigger than these
and if you synchronize the axes
let's go back before we named him
okay synchronize the axis then we don't
need both of these headers so we can
come here and click show header and we
just have the one let's do the same
thing on sales by year
synchronize
always good to make sure that your axes
are either synchronized or well labeled
and let's hide it let's see what it
looks like now
great
okay one thing to keep in mind
when we do
filter to just one region
the lines are going to end up at the
same spot
if we filter to two
then it's only the sum of those two
so
perhaps the header overall sales and
overall profit isn't quite accurate
because it isn't overall necessarily
when we have it filtered um why does
this happen
why doesn't this line always show the
total no matter what you select here
well that's because this filter applies
to the whole dashboard so it filters
this line to those regions just as much
as it filters these lines
so i'm going to remove out that tooltip
line because it could be a little
misleading
let's continue on and make a dashboard
that digs a little bit more into sales
specifically great so we'll make our
first sheet we'll call it
sales by region
and we're going to make another pie
chart so
let's do it using show me we'll click on
region
and then we will control click on sales
open up show me click pie
close it again great so now we have the
sales by region pi we'll make it the
entire view and when you hover you can
see that it's showing us sales in dollar
amounts now it would be
more
like a pie for it to be percentages so a
lot of pies each of these slices is
shown as a percentage of the whole
at one hundred percent so let's come
here to our slice size we'll right click
on it and we're going to use what's
called a quick table calculation
and change it to percent of total so now
when you hover you can see that the west
is 31
of the pie
great
let's also label each of these slices so
i'm going to control click and drag
region onto label
and add region to the labels i'm going
to undo that and show you what would
happen if i just dragged region onto
labels without copying it without
holding ctrl it will move it
and get rid of our colors and we don't
want that so we're going to control and
drag another way to do this let's go
back is by taking region and dragging it
onto label just straight from over here
but in this case for the sum of sales
where we've applied the quick table
calculation we want that quick table
calculation to also show up in our label
so i'm going to control and drag
and it brings that quick table
calculation along with it if i were to
undo just drag sales on it's going to go
back to that dollar amount and i'm going
to have to add another quick table
calculation so instead ctrl and drag
that's probably one of my very favorite
tableau tricks great now let's add a
filter for region so i'm going to right
click here and click show filter and we
will make sure that this gets added to
all of our sheets once we've made them
all
okay next sheet we're going to call this
sheet
sales by state
let's do a map great so um one way to
get your map started is to double click
on any of these dimensions that have a
globe next to them so since we want to
go with state we can double click on
state
and it starts mapping out state so what
it does is it adds latitude and
longitude to our rows and columns that
are generated here and another way to
get going so let's go back is to click
on the geographic part you want and then
control click on sales like we did for
map sorry for our pie chart come over to
show me and choose one of our maps we
could do it with the circles but we're
going to do a field map
click on that so now we have our field
map based on state
we can choose one of these different
palettes if we'd like let's try this one
or blue teal
or we could do green so that darker
green means more money
great so now we have all of our states
colored by sales let's also control and
drag sales onto label
and you can see we have the dollar sign
and the money formatting that we made
earlier and let's control and drag state
onto label
now maybe we want the state to be on top
so we can click on label and it pops up
with all these different options and if
we want to edit the text you can click
here
on the ellipses
and edit it there so let's cut state
and paste it
at the top there i think i lost my
center alignment so we'll do that again
hit apply see what we think
great okay so now you can see that puts
the state on top you can also see in
some of these places where they're super
close together that you can't see all of
the state's labels and that's because
this option here in labels is unchecked
allow labels to overlap other marks so
tableau senses when the marks are too
close together and it's going to become
too hard to read and we'll hide anything
that overlaps with each other if we
click this option now you see everything
but it gets a little crowded over here
so let's unselect that and you'll be
able to see what the sales are upon
hover
great now we have our sales by state
for filters for this one let's no let's
right click on sales here and click show
filter so basically wherever you're
using your metrics your dimensions or
your measures you can right click on
them
and create your filters um so now we
could uh the lowest amount for a state
is 920
for sales for this time period and we
could filter out ones that have sales
lower than that but
i think this isn't what i want let's
remove that filter let's do it for the
state show filter great so now we could
filter out
a state we could just show
arizona
or show them all
excellent let's move on to our next
visualization new sheet
rename it to be called sales by
sub category
great so we're going to drag on category
onto columns and subcategory we could
either drag on subcategory here or
because of our hierarchy press plus now
we have subcategory and category and
let's bring on sales it's defaulting to
this bar chart which is perfect that's
what i want and now we could color it by
subcategory and this is a discrete
coloring we could also color it by
sales
and this is a continuous coloring so the
darkest corresponds with the height now
we don't need to do this there is
already an indicator of who has the most
sales and that's based on the bar height
so if we wanted to color it by
subcategory then each one of them gets
their own color we could color it by
category to
add to
the distinction between the different
categories so that's very clear
where they start and stop let's do by
sub category excellent so now we have
three different dashboards oh let's add
some filters for subcategory so let's
bring on
category as our filter so we'll right
click here click show filter there's
category and let's do a filter for
our date so we're going to come here to
order date let's drag it onto filters
and let's click years
now these are all the years options
we'll click all
and hit ok right click here and click
show filter
so now instead of doing a range where we
could drag that line now we have
discrete filter and so we can check and
uncheck boxes to choose what years we
want to see
awesome let's start with our dashboard
let's call this dashboard
our sales dashboard and change our size
if you have any questions about
different sizes what's available here be
sure to ask that in the comments below
and
let's start with pulling on our sales by
region so last time we pulled on a chart
we saw that it added the legend for us
but this time you can see it added both
the legends
and the filter so last time we created
the filters after we built the dashboard
but this time you can see that the
filter um gets brought in when we
brought in the dashboard let's do our
sales by state side by side here and
let's do sales by subcategory underneath
so i dragged it you can see how i pull
it towards the bottom of the dashboard
and it kind of fills in the space where
it's going to be
and then brings it in so now it's
brought in all our filters and all of
our legends it defaults to putting the
filters and legends over here we're
going to click select layout layout
container it's going to select what's
what they're all inside of and we're
going to make it take up this whole side
but it doesn't need that much space
so you can see in tableau there's a lot
of dragging there's a lot of dropping
and um
a lot of resizing to get things the way
you want them to be give our map more
room
and we have a mixture over here of
legends and
filters let's move our legends out of
there so we can grab this legend and
come and put it on this side
and this legend come put it over here
so that we're getting a little bit more
near the visualizations they belong to
this legend goes up here with this one
i'm going to actually click here and
change it from
a tiled so right here it says tiled
object to a floating object that lets it
sit on top of a visualization i'm going
to put it on top of this visualization
right up here
excellent and then we have this one
that's showing us the size of sales
that's because on this dashboard it says
that size is determined by sales but
since it's just one
circle there's no size comparison so
it's not like we have several circles
and we have to look and see which one's
the biggest so that we can tell that the
amount of sales so we don't need this
legend and we can just remove it from
the dashboard let's clean up
some of these we have several different
versions of what your
filters could look like so my personal
favorite is multiple values drop down it
gives you some of the most flexibility
but if you wanted them to only be able
to select a single value you could turn
it into a radio button list so that it's
a selected all or it's one at a time
you could also do a drop down or a
slider and make that happen
a slider is a little bit different from
a range on the range you can see that we
could edit either side and it's picking
everything in between but with discrete
values if you say everything in between
it doesn't make a lot of sense because
what's everything between furniture and
technology we don't know that office
supplies goes between those there's no
order so
let's do
multiple value drop downs
for big ones like state there is the
option
of searching so i know i want utah and i
search and there's utah
instead of having to scroll through the
list this could be really helpful for if
you had a filter for by products and
that would allow somebody to look at
just one product at a time if they know
their name of the product but also not
have to just open up the product list
and scroll and scroll and scroll since
there are very a lot of products so we
can filter by region by doing this oh
this is a great reminder you saw that
this did not change all the
visualizations we have yet to apply
these filters to all the worksheets so
let's do that right now apply to
worksheets selected worksheets and we
will click all on dashboard
hit ok
we'll do this again
until we have selected them all
great so it's really nice you get to
choose what worksheets you wanted to
apply to because in the event that you
had maybe um a total number up here at
the top that you just wanted to stay the
same all the time no matter what they
selected you could make that happen by
not selecting that worksheet to be
changed by these filters okay great so
we can change what region we're looking
at by selecting central here and then
we're just looking at central throughout
all the visualizations i love looking at
it on a map and seeing just one at a
time it just really makes the region
name just stand out to you but if we
wanted to use this as our filter to
filter the rest of the dashboards we can
click this uses filter button and now
when we click on central here it stays
in context here but the other two
dashboards change
one thing you may notice is that texas
is not the darkest on this chart because
of the scale the scale goes up to half a
million there but then when we click on
central the scale updates just for
what's selected so everything else is
filtered out and now the darkest of the
dark is only a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars and texas becomes the
darkest on the visualization there are
some ways you can change that but if
you're wondering why do my colors look a
little differently when i filter that's
why
great we could also click use this
filter here so if we just wanted to look
at texas we click this this updates to
just central this updates to just texas
down here and unselect
by
clicking on maybe another state or when
you click on the state again it should
unselect and we could do the same thing
here or if we just want to look at one
subcategory and say
let me scroll down a bit storage now
everything updates to the storage it's
interesting i wouldn't have known very
quickly that there are some states that
didn't have any storage sales but now
when we click on storage we can tell i
showed you before that you can control
click and look at binders and storage
and it puts those two together also in
tableau you can drag
and we could select all of these so we
have art binders envelopes fasteners
labels paper and storage and none of
those are getting sold here
i don't know what's up with wyoming
excellent so now we have our sales
dashboard and
let's get started on our next one our
next dashboard is going to be the profit
version of this dashboard so some of
these visualizations we can use again so
let's go to sales by region right click
and click duplicate
rename it to
profit by region
now you have to be careful whenever you
go to reuse a visualization because like
i mentioned before you got to make sure
everywhere
that sales is used you have to replace
it with profit i'm also going to drag
this sheet to be
more at the end here after the sales
dashboard just to keep them separate so
that we have the sheets that lead up to
overall than the sheets that lead up to
sales and then we'll have the sheets
that lead up to profit great so we'll
grab profit and drag it onto angle size
and that updates the angle size drag it
onto the size of the circle shouldn't
make a difference since we only have one
circle and onto the text now when i
dragged it on it didn't do the percent
of total anymore so let's change that to
the quick table calculation of percent
of total for there and for
the label
percent of total there we go now we have
our percent total again by region region
okay here's another thing since we
duplicated that filter it's going to be
using that exact same filter
you see it's using region from sales by
region all the sales dashboards we don't
want that so let's remove out all the
filters here
and these action filters that are
generated by our filtering that those
come from
this
these are called action filters
and it's generated when we click this
uses filter button okay back to profit
by region great we're clear of filters
and let's add back in a region filter
and this one no longer has the icon
that shows you that it affects multiple
sheets which is what we want for now so
you might want perhaps there would be a
situation where you would have two
dashboards and you would want these
filters that you put on here to affect
both dashboards and in this case that's
not what i want great so another one we
can use the basics for is sales by
subcategory so let's duplicate that
great profit by subcategory already
exists we made this earlier tableau will
not allow you to make worksheet that has
the same name as another worksheet you
can
call it number one or since it does put
the title up here you can put an extra
space at the end or it does detect that
space it counts it as a different title
even though it's the same title just
with a space that does cause some issues
so like when we're looking here and
we're saying oh profit by subcategory i
want that oh this is when we made it but
you don't want this one you want this
one and it gets a little confusing the
nice thing is when you're dragging
things onto your dashboard when you
hover you should get a little picture
here of what dashboard what
visualization you're looking at it
really helps you to make your decisions
and not just have to do it by name if
you're a little bit disorganized and you
have all these called sheet 5 sheet 7
you won't know exactly what that is
right away so that little preview is
very helpful great profit by subcategory
we'll do the same thing by removing out
all our filters so i just click on it
and hit delete
you can also control click
and then hit delete or you can drag them
off into a space that's not the
visualization space great and we only
have some of sales right there so we'll
change that to profit
and we have some negative profits there
we'll keep the colors the same for
consistency between the two dashboards
and let's bring on
category as a filter okay
show filter there we are and let's do
our order date filter right now order
date we'll do years okay
all the years so it gives you this
option here because it assumes that
you're making a filter because you want
this dashboard to just be filtered to
your selection you can do that you can
make a filter that isn't exposed to the
end user so let's say you were making a
big dashboard and it was just focused on
furniture then and you don't want them
to be able to select a different
category for because of your analysis
you can make that happen
you can just click furniture and not
show this by clicking hide card here but
in this case we want to be able to make
this interactive
in a lot of different ways great profit
by subcategory exists now instead of our
map we're going to make an area chart
so i'll rename this and call it
profit
over time
by category
so we're going to
bring on our order date into columns and
it goes to our discrete value let's
change it to our continuous value so we
get the axis let's grab our profit onto
rows and it makes us a line chart we're
going to change that to an area chart an
area chart is nice because when you
split it up by category by dragging
category onto color you can now see
what category is responsible for how
much profit like you do with a line
chart however its area is what defines
that so you can see that area over time
and do comparisons and also it stacks
them on top of each other so that you
can tell that for 2013 our profit was
around fifty thousand dollars really
quickly otherwise we have to add that
line this line here and it makes these
lines smaller and lower um more
difficult to see so
back to our profit over time by category
so that's some of the benefits of having
an area chart and if we wanted to go a
little more detailed than here you hit
this plus and now we have over quarter
we have some negative profits that's
interesting but let's go back to over
the year great and for this one we're
gonna make one more pie chart so we
could start from scratch or we could
duplicate our profit by region pie chart
which i'm going to do
we're going to do this for the
comparison between a pie chart and an
area chart so it's going to be profit by
category
but not over time so right now it's
profit by region let's drag category
right on top of colors there
and now it's split up
having some trouble because it's
splitting it by category but because of
we brought region onto text it's also
splitting it by region so we have region
region region region inside of this
category and we don't want that so we're
going to drag category right on top of
region here as well and now it's just
the three segments so whatever you have
in this marks card unless it's on
tooltips will affect your level of
detail in the visualization here when
it's on tool tips sometimes it won't
change the level of detail but it could
have an effect on like so if we brought
oh let's do this right now so right now
the level of detail of this chart does
not go to the category by
region like it did before you can bring
it onto detail here and it won't affect
color and it won't affect labels but it
will change the detail and you see how
it splits it out again this is what it
would look like if it's by region by
category and you have much more slices
to this pie we'll go back but if we take
region and put it onto tool tip it's not
at a low enough level for that tool tip
to make any sense so it's going to put
that star you see region is star that's
because this section of the pie covers
multiple regions if we filtered the
region to just central now it populates
so there are sometimes benefits to
having it in there even when
at all levels it doesn't make any sense
but we won't leave it there
excellent so you can see
how the color is what determines
is a big part of what determines how
many slices you get the level of detail
for the whole chart is a big factor as
well on how many slices you get great
profit by region profit by category by
subcategory and by
profit over time and we have
our category filter we don't have our
subcategory filter yet we grabbed
category
but let's right click on subcategory and
click show filter there we go now we
have a filter for category and
subcategory
here's our region one
we have region in two places and we
don't want that
we wanted to apply to all of them we'll
do that when we get to the dashboard
and
we have category year of order date and
sub category great those are all the
filters i wanted so let's build our
dashboard
we'll call this our profit dashboard
once i get it set
to the size i want
profit we'll start with profit by
region
and we'll have our profit by category
over time next to it great
we'll give that
some different space have this at the
bottom
have this underneath there
now it's bunched all these up
next to it so let's again drag it over
to the side it's always good to pay
attention to the highlighted section and
it gives you kind of an idea oh you see
i accidentally dragged an individual
filter instead of this whole section so
when i grabbed this i didn't grab all of
these so if you want to grab all of
these and they happen to be inside the
same section you can come and click
select a layout container and now i'm
grabbing all of them
there we go
we'll do the same thing as before you
know what i'm going to make these
floating
because then it kind of sits inside of
that same area i'll make that one
floating
and this one too
this category
legend applies to both this chart and
this chart so that's very nice and this
subcategory legend i won't make floating
i'll just put here by subcategory
and this profit by category doesn't need
quite that much space
let's give
our bar chart some room
excellent we don't need the size of the
circles
make these
drop downs now
because i didn't have to on
this chart and this chart change profit
to dollars because we set that as the
default it definitely saved us some time
so
i recommend setting default number
formatting
at the beginning of your visualizations
really nice
excellent now you can rearrange the
order of these so i like to have the
date at the top it's sometimes hard to
get it to the top so i take it the
second to the top and i drag the top one
down and then um category above
subcategory just for logical sense
excellent and we have our profit
dashboard let's see there is this check
box down here called show dashboard
title so if we wanted to have the title
at the top here you can click that
button any floating objects
don't shift down
like everything else did
there we go so we could have that title
we could not have that title
that's up to you excellent so at this
point we have our overall dashboard that
looks at sales and profit we have our
sales dashboard and we have our profit
dashboard our profit dashboard isn't 100
complete because i forgot to make sure
all of these filters apply to all of
these worksheets so let's go ahead and
do that right now
applied worksheets selected worksheets
all on dashboard
one thing that is nice from this view
it's really nice to click on dashboard
and you only see the ones on the
dashboard but you can click here and say
show all worksheets in workbook and you
can see the rest here so if you wanted
all on the dashboard and you wanted this
one or something like that then you have
the option to see them all
great perfect so before you ever publish
a dashboard it's always good to double
check that your filters work
when you filter to just one
year this area chart becomes a lot less
useful but if you're looking at two or
more
you start to see the shape of it
great
now we're going to take a look at
linking from our overall dashboard
to our sales
dashboard great so we'll go to our
overall dashboard and we'll be creating
what's called an action
so you can make an action
on a worksheet
you can see right here
actions or on a dashboard actions so
since we're linking between two
dashboards this is going to be a
dashboard action
sorry just trying to unhighlight there
but if you're ever looking for an action
you made and you can't find it look in
the other one great this is our actions
dialog box here we can see the highlight
that has been generated when it says
generated next to it that means that you
didn't come in and define an action it
was made by
clicking
this highlight button here that'll
generate an action
or when we look on our sales dashboard
we clicked on this uses filter button so
we should have several actions here that
were all generated
we have a couple different kinds of
actions
when you go to make an action
there's a filter action that we see when
we click use filter a highlight action
that we can see from here in region and
go to url action that we haven't used if
you have any questions about go to url
please post them in the comments below
it basically allows you to be able to
select a url here and so
if you had a dashboard that had to do
with maybe stocks you could put in a url
here and then put your stock ticker
symbol there so that you could have a
url that would then take you to a
finance website that shows you your
stock information
it can get pretty cool okay but we want
to
link from this dashboard to one of our
other dashboards and you actually do
that using a filter action so we're
going to name that action go
to
sales dashboard
and we wanted to happen when we click on
our sales sheet so you see right here it
shows us the two sheets that are on this
dashboard when we click on the profits
dashboard we don't want this action to
occur this is our go to sales dashboard
now you can have an action occur on
hover
or select you've seen select happen
that's what our filter uses filter
actions use and on menu so we're gonna
do it on menu
and the targeted sheets it defaults to
this dashboard saying when i click on
this i want the rest of this dashboard
to update but instead it's going to take
us to our sales dashboard
so when we click on this i want these
sheets to update now we're going to
define what filters it's going to apply
by default it's going to apply all of
the filters based on what we click so if
we click here it will filter to just
2013
let's say we click here it'll filter to
just 2013 and it will filter to the
region we selected
so
let's see what happens when we do that
okay it's just going to default okay now
when i click on this it's going to
filter to 2013 and west go to sales
dashboard this is where it pops up when
you have it on menu
it's taken us to our sales dashboard it
is filtered 2013 and west
just so you know actions will not affect
these filters here you see that it
thinks all of them are selected because
it creates a separate filter there is
such thing as show only relevant values
for these filters so if we click this it
will filter this to only the ones that
are relevant so we can see that it's
only 2013 that this dashboard is
filtered down to but if we click all
values in the database this filter
doesn't have any only one particularly
selected it does have them all selected
right now
so
we can get here
for that information and to get back
we just need to navigate back to overall
great so it works there
but when we click on this up here
go to sales dashboard
we get a blank dashboard now
that happens because it's trying to pass
region information to that dashboard
but this doesn't have any region detail
on this line it doesn't know what that
is so it's giving it a bad region value
so let's fix this
go to our actions we're going to edit
our go to sales dashboard and we're
going to select what fields
it'll filter on
we will filter on
our order date
year
and
let me go back to that
we clicked order date year and it goes
to the target data source sometimes your
target data source will be a different
data source than the one that you are
using for your source data source now
that gets a little bit complicated right
now we're just using one data source so
that's not something you need to worry
about in a simple visualization like
this
okay and we're gonna add one more
we're gonna add region
and it automatically selects region over
here but you could select it yourself
let's see what happens here okay if
one dashboard has region in it and the
other dashboard doesn't have region in
it or doesn't allow you to filter by
region then sometimes you'll get an
error here that will say it's missing
out of your target dashboards
so we don't have any errors so let's see
what happens
so we go to click here go to sales
dashboard
what if
we
take out region
remove region and we're just doing it
based on year
okay okay click here go to sales
dashboard and there everything is
so now
it will filter back to the year that you
selected so this is all 2013 but it will
not filter to the region you selected
so even when we come here and we select
west
it takes you to the dashboard but it
doesn't filter it to west
you have to do that yourself
so now we have links
from sales to
sales let's make one for profit to
profit
go to sales dashboard add action
filter
we're going to call this go to profit
dashboard
and we're only going to come from the
profit table to make this happen
let's go to profit and let's select our
fields
we're going to do the same thing
where it's only going to filter it to
the year
now you can see oh i started to type in
i didn't show you this before but you
can
search text so i started typing in year
and it shows you that under order date
you have all these different options in
this dashboard right now if you remember
we're using the continuous one that is
marked by
the little calendar
so that's it knows it's a calendar date
instead of just
trading it like a discrete field
okay
excellent go to profit dashboard and
there we go this visualization like we
said when it's filtered to just one year
isn't quite as useful but one thing you
can do
is for west here we can select
both years i'm i'm going to do it by
control clicking click
click
go to profit dashboard
and now we've got 2015 and 2016. so
that's how you do linking between the
two dashboards if you wanted to be able
to include region as well
you could
put a note in the tooltip for this that
this doesn't work for
region linking from this area it doesn't
work or perhaps you could not have this
total line on the same visualization you
could have a separate visualization that
shows the total or an area chart instead
and that will let you not have this
problem of go to sales dashboard not
linking appropriately
so now we're going to create our final
dashboard our segment dashboard and it's
going to use
a parameter in it so we'll get to take a
look at parameters on dashboards
so let's rename this we're going to call
it
profit
and sales
by segment
you don't have to name all of your
dashboards a description of what they
are but it makes it really nice and easy
and it automatically puts it up here but
if you wanted to change this you can
just come in here and name this whatever
you like and then it will just show up
up here so
we could call this segment analysis
click apply or ok and there it goes
that means this and this does not have
to be the same
if we go forward again segment analysis
and profit and sales by segment that
allows you to have some
more useful names down here that make it
easy when you're looking at them side by
side but have a name to match your
dashboard up here great so we're going
to
make
a profit in sales is going to be a bars
and circles chart and we're going to
bring in our segment that we haven't
looked at yet
consumer corporate and home office and
then we're going to look at it segment
and we're going to make a matrix with
category and we get to fill in this
space with our
visualizations so we're gonna do sales
and it's going to make these bar charts
so we can see for technology by consumer
by corporate by home office and that is
a matrix of bar charts but we also want
to be able to see profit
and right now it's making two sets of
visualizations but we want just one so
let's dual axis
and it's automatically changed it to
circles also it is not
synchronizing the axis now because
profit is blue and these profit is not
anywhere near the same amount as sales
which makes sense you shouldn't have
profit that's higher than sales so let's
synchronize our axis
and let's change our sales our marks
card over here is associated with sales
it's nice and easy when the two marks
cards are based on a different measure
to let you know which one you're
affecting and we'll change that to a bar
and now we have a circle on
a bar chart now if we had profit in
front of sales
you can see how it's behind and you can
fix that by taking it to the back of
sales
another way you can fix it
say you want it the profit access here
over here for some reason you can right
click on the axis and put mark type or
oh move marks to front another way to
change it we don't need both of these
so let's not show that header and we
don't need this to be labeled profit
because it's for both of them so the way
you get rid of that is actually you
click edit axis
and then you just erase the title
oh and you don't hit reset you just
erase the title
and then you close it
so now no title here but we still have
the axes
and we have three sets of bar charts
across excellent the next chart we're
going to build oh so right now they are
it automatically added the colors based
on measure names measure names is a
dimension that is created by tableau and
it's just what it sounds like we're
coloring it based on the different
measure names one of them's named profit
one of them's named sales and we know
that you can come here click color and
hit edit colors and it will open this
dialog box but you can also come here
and double click on a color pops open
that dialog box let's
pick a palette
let's see
there's a lot of different ones of these
tableau 20
let's pick colors from this palette
profit can be
so you click here make sure it's
highlighted click the color you want
click here make sure it's highlighted
click the color you want
hit apply
and then you can come to color and make
it a little more opaque
whatever when you make it more opaque
you start to be able to see through your
circles there are benefits but also
drawbacks to doing that
anyway
so stick with the tableau orange blue
great we have our first chart our next
chart is going to be called
top
customers buy sales and this is where
we're going to use our parameter where
we made our top end customers so
let's bring in our sum of sales make a
bar chart for that and then we're also
going to we're bringing in our set now
so we have our in and our out we're
going to break up our set
by our segment as it's part of our
segment analysis and we'll bring in our
customer names
and let's sort it excellent now you can
see that when we sorted it it didn't
take this big guy and put it all the way
at the top it just sorted it each within
its own section great and so here we
have our in and out and that's not a
super user-friendly title for
our users of this dashboard they're like
in and out of top end customers by sales
maybe we want this to say something a
little bit more user-friendly so let's
make a calculated field and we're going
to call it the top and customers
label
and we're going to go and say if
and we're going to use our set top end
customers by sales and since it's an in
their outset it treats this like
if it's in top end customers by sales
then
top
we're gonna
um do with string so it's gonna be top
and then we wanna use the number that's
in our parameter so we have to convert
it from a number to a string and we have
to concatenate them together in tableau
you can use a plus sign top and always
make sure you have space between what
you're concatenating together that's
something that i tend to forget
top space customers so if they pick 20
it'll say top 20 customers
so if it's in this set then top blank
customers
else if it's not in the set we will just
call it other and in tableau you always
need to end your if statement with an
end here it tells us our calculation is
valid while we're here i want to show
you a little trick there's this arrow
button here
that can give you all of the different
functions that are available within
tableau
and it even sorts it out by different
categories so if we didn't know how to
make this into a string we could go to
type conversion we could click on string
and it gives you an example also when
you click on
a function in here did you see how it's
on date and then i clicked on string and
i'm like what does this do click on it
and it tells me so this makes it really
useful inside of tableau also in tableau
you can make a comment in here so if
somebody's like what's going on here you
can press dash dash or
slash slash and type in
this is a more user-friendly
title hit okay and there we go we have
our more user-friendly title we drag it
here we see our top 20 customers and
other and we don't want to show this
anymore but we still want it in place
you can click right click on it up here
and click show header and it hides it so
that in out is still happening there and
let's drag it to our filters and there
we have it we have our top link
customers and it tells you right there
how many and we need to come here to
parameter right click and click show
parameter control and that's how we can
control
these changes so let's set it to 10 at
first and we have it our top customers
by sales but it's interesting to know
profit as well so we have really big
sales but how is their profit doing so
let's drive profit on color and you can
see this person has a negative amount of
profit despite their big sales so that's
important for us to know and we can
change our color like we did previously
to go from
red to blue
and we can
change our center to zero
and now we can see the negatives really
quickly
now they're not the only one either i
have a negative profit but some of our
highest sales that's great to know
excellent those are our visualizations
for the segment dashboard so let's talk
about filters really quick we have this
filter we won't show the filter itself
we don't want to allow them to show in
or out we just are going to allow them
to show how many but we do want to be
able to have them filter by category so
let's show that filter and by segment
show that filter and and then we'll have
our parameter
great let's make our dashboard
um automatic as you probably read right
there the dashboard will resize to fit
any screen it is displayed on that can
be really handy especially if your
visualization is really dynamic and can
change however some visualizations like
this visualization for example if it
gets too squished you stop being able to
read things very well so automatic has
its definite pros and cons
so we're going to bring on our profit
and sales by segment and it already pops
up with its
legend and total customers
by sale and it pops up with its legends
and filters and it pops up with its
parameter now i'm going to close that
and be like if you don't see your
parameter when you first bring it in the
parameter is affecting this sheet and
you can go to parameters and find it but
parameters are
workbook wide meaning that it's going to
exist over here too
uh it doesn't affect this sheet however
it's still going to show up there
because it could affect it is available
for any sheet and it's the same there is
no determining what worksheets this
affects this will affect any sheet that
it is on so if i i've changed it to 10
and if i come down here and go back to
the other visualization that uses it
this is why i should name my sheets
let's see if i can find it
nope
here we are sheet 13. in cheat 13
we have our top 10. so i've got a 10 and
i've got a 10 over there and if i change
it to 20
and i go back to my segment dashboard
it is also changed to 20. so it will
affect all sheets always very important
to know great so here's our
visualization
here are some of the more useful legends
so
let's
make this floating and put it over by
the visualization it matters for we can
do the same thing here floating right up
here floating does not work very well
for if you were to make this an
automatic dashboard so that the size
changes all the time because floating
could end up right on top of your
visualization and keep you from being
able to see what you need to see
and let's make these affect
all the dashboards in the workbook
again we don't have to do this for our
parameter
it will already affect all the
dashboards in the whole
workbook
and
format these
another thing you should know is that
there are more formatting options for
these
including edit title so it's already
named it category automatically but if
you had
like here oh this is a great example
edit title top end customers and you
could change it to
select
number of top customers
or something like that give it a little
more space
and yeah these floating ones do not
shift when you shift things so it's
always good to double check your
floating legends
and this is a little bit more user
friendly
than the title we made for the
developers
that's using parameters in a dashboard
today in this video we learned about an
overview of business intelligence on
tableau we talked about how to install
tableau public and how to connect to a
data source
we also talked about creating calculated
fields
like this one
we talked about making sets and
parameters we learned how to make a
donut chart
and a 2d donut chart we learned about
making dashboards
and adding filters to those dashboards
and we also learned about connecting
between dashboards
today we will be learning about the
topics we discussed in part one live
versus extract data sources we'll talk
about joins and unions and we'll look at
table calculations we'll look at the
rank functions and we'll look at actions
specifically url actions we'll talk
about reference lines and bands we'll
look into some insights in the data such
as delay analysis also we'll learn how
to build a waterfall chart and then
finally we will learn about level of
detail calculations while making two
different visualizations
in part one of this tableau training we
introduced tableau basics and we learned
how to create
donut charts and two-dimensional donut
charts and we learned about linking
between dashboards if you missed part
one please check out the link in the
description below
now let's discuss the difference between
a live connection and an extract
connection first it's important to note
that these different types of
connections are not available in tableau
public it's always a live connection and
a live connection is where the data will
update based on when the source of the
data updates so if any if you're
connected to a database and something in
the database changes then you'll pick up
those changes when you open the report
as it will query that database
when the report is opened whereas an
extract connection
is extracted into creates a subset of
the data that improves performance so
when you're looking at it locally on
your computer you have an extract of
that data set that subset of the data
right on your computer or up in tableau
server depending on where you're looking
at it and it does not update
when the database updates it only
updates when your refresh updates it so
without a refresh set for that extract
you won't get the new data as an example
of this let's say
that in our
sample superstore we have kelly williams
associated with the central region but
that's changed so let's go ahead and
change that
we will change it to
sarah smith
and
we'll save it
now let's go back to our tableau
workbooks
and you can see we can refresh it over
here and see sarah smith come in over
here in our extract it sarah smith
doesn't come in
if we click to refresh the extract it
doesn't refresh the extract until we
navigate to sheet 1
but when we go back to our data source
then we see sarah smith coming in so
that refresh can be scheduled and it
could run once a day
or once every several hours
but you would need to set up a refresh
or else you would never get sarah
smith's data coming in
next let's talk about joining data in
tableau so here we have the people table
but let's say we want to join it to our
orders information so i'm going to start
with our orders table
and then we're going to pull on people
and tableau is going to
create a join for us and it's going to
choose the column that we would like to
join on based on the names in the two
data sources so if these two data
sources didn't have a column that had
the same name then tableau wouldn't be
able to guess what
two to join on
so we would have to come in and select
out of the order side
and the people side
what we'd like to join on and then we
have the options to do an inner join a
left join a right join and a full outer
join let's review quickly what these
look like so say we had two tables that
we wanted to join together one of them
was the student table that had the
student names and the key to their grade
and which we could use to look up their
grade over here in the grade table which
had the key to their grade and the
actual grade a b c d f and incomplete
we can see here that somebody has made a
mistake and put in a letter grade
instead of the key to the letter grade
and we'll see how that affects what
we're looking at
so if we were to do an inner join
that would only take
the rows where the join could complete
so
we have one that could join to one just
fine but we don't have two and we don't
have three a doesn't join to anything so
this row would be
not included and then four
five
and six would all join so that would
look something like this where we would
see adam
um when we grab student from this table
and grade from this table we can see
adam had an a beverly had an a dale had
a d elizabeth had an f and frank is
incomplete and charles is missing also
you don't see
any b or c in this list of grades
for a left join
it's going to take everything
from the left table
and only the pieces from the right table
that apply to the left table so it looks
pretty similar to our inner join
only charles shows up so the join wasn't
able to complete since a doesn't exist
in grade but we include charles anyways
and grade
becomes null
for charles it won't put in the grade
key because it's we're not asking for
the grade key we're asking for grade
from the grade table so we try to look
up a inside of the grade table we can't
find it and never tolerance no we look
up a inside the grade key perfect right
join is like a left join only it takes
everything from the right table instead
of the left table so it grabs all the
grades a b c d f and incomplete and only
the rows from the left table that join
appropriately
so since charles doesn't join
appropriately he doesn't show up we also
have b and c showing up
even though it doesn't exist in the
student table
and it won't be tied to a student
because that join wasn't able to
complete as it didn't exist over there
and the last one is a full outer join
where it takes everything from both
tables
whether or not the join is complete so
we have all of the people where the join
completes we also have charles where the
join doesn't complete from the left to
the right and we have b and c where the
join doesn't complete from the right to
the left
so those are our options in tableau
here
in our sample superstore data set
you could look and see if there are any
regions in the orders table that don't
exist in the people table and that's how
you can know what kind of join you want
and so if you want those orders to still
show up even though they don't have a
region
or their region is
not in
the people table that's when you would
do a left join
for our purposes
we'll do an inner join
now let's say
we had a second
excel sheet here
that had more
orders and you can do a union
which is just adding more orders
by dragging that second orders table
right underneath the original orders
table you can see it says their drag
table to union and that's helpful for if
you have an excel sheet for maybe
different years so say you had a
separate excel sheet for the orders in
2015 and then another one for the orders
in 2016 you could pull on your 2015
orders and then drag your 2016 orders
right there to union and it would take
these orders and then
add the rows instead of the columns
for the 2016 orders
for example we've added people
but as a join and that will
first put in all of our orders
as columns and then add the columns for
our person
but if we were adding more data that
fell under the order
columns so it would have the same data
the same order id ship date but we
wanted to add more rows then that would
be when you union
now we're going to take a look at
calculations and which ones are
calculated on the database side versus
which are calculated on the table side
so here we have percentage of total
sales split up by sub category and
category
we also have
percentage of total sales a long table
down so the difference between these two
things are one of them is made using
a calculated field
which is where we do the sum of sales
divided by the sum of fixed sum of sales
this part is called a level of detail
calculation
and this calculation the sum of sales
and the sum of the level of detail of
sales
which basically makes the database find
the total
sum of sales regardless of
these dimensions we pulled on
so it gives us our total number so this
will be sum of sales for bookcases and
this will be sum of sales for everything
this calculation is done on the database
side whereas this one
percentage of total sales along table
down is what's called a table
calculation
it's a quick table calculation of
percent of total and it is done
in tableau it's processed locally right
inside of the table after the
aggregations have occurred
there are some pros and cons of doing it
this way so
for
this percent of total sales
i had to create the table calculation
here
and it does the fixed
sum of sales where it finds the sum of
sales for the entire database and since
it is fixed it will ignore filters so
for example
i took off both of the sales and i'm
just going to put on the percent sum of
sales and let's say we wanted to see
how office supplies and technology are
as percentages of sum of sales
and ignore furniture so we can grab
category and we'll control
click and drag
and we're going to unselect furniture
and hit ok
now it's still
taking it out of the total sum of sales
including furniture and so our grand
total down here is only 67 instead of
100
whereas
if we take
sales and double click it and it adds it
over here on the table then we right
click and do a quick table calculation
and click
percent of total
this one is doing it out of 100 and
these numbers don't match
and that's because it does take into
account the filter of category so let's
pull the filter of category off and we
can see that they're both out of 100 now
and each of these take into account
the same amount of data since we have no
filters here
so if you wanted to take into account
the filters on the table
then you need to use a table calculation
however when you push the information
back to the database to do the
calculation it's doing it as part of the
query to the data source and it can save
you some time and so which one of these
is faster sort of depends on
what data is available already when the
original query comes back
next we're going to discuss ranking in
tableau
first let's add a second data source so
we can do that by coming up to data and
clicking new data source
or you can just click this plus data
source right here and click microsoft
excel
we're going to use this rank example
worksheet
perfect and it's already pulled in the
sheet we want because there's only one
sheet
and we'll go to sheet2
pull on store
pull on sales
and we will rename sheet2
as
rank example
great so now we have here's all of our
stores and here are our sales and if we
wanted to rank them
based on who had the highest sales to
the lowest sales we could create a
calculated field
called ranked by sales
and we're going to use our rank
function
and we're going to put in sales now we
receive this error here so when we hover
we see what that arrow says oh you can
click and it says all fields must be
aggregate or constant when using table
calculation functions or fields from
multiple data sources so we learn
something unique here
that you might not know is that a rank
is a table calculation
and it requires it to be aggregated
so
we can make sum
and put the parentheses around sales
and our error goes away so now we know
rank is a table calculation
and we have our box here that expands
out and can teach us about what we're
using here so when i click on rank it
will tell us that it returns the
standard competition rank for the
current row
and it says identical values are
assigned an identical rank so let's see
what that looks like we'll hit okay
we'll double click on rank by sales and
we can see our ranks so e had the
highest sales so it's one
d is next and c and b are tied
20 and 20
and so they both share the rank of three
and then because they are two of them
that share the same rank we skip four
and the next one gets fifth place
but now this isn't the only way to rank
so let's make another one of these
we'll click duplicate
and edit
let's erase copy
and we're going to call this rank dense
by sales
double click on rank start typing rank
again and we're going to click rank
dense
now the difference here is that rank
dense returns the rank where identical
values are assigned an identical rank
but no gaps are inserted in the numbers
so click ok double click rank dense and
you can see instead of going one two
three five
it goes one two three four
so it doesn't include that gap
now let's give them a little bit more
space here
and maybe i want it to be in the order i
created it so these measure values are
defining what's going to happen up here
so we can take sales and put it at the
top and that'll move sales to the front
and put rank dense at the bottom so now
we can see sales we can see rank by
sales we rank dense by sales
now let's duplicate
and look at the next one
we have rank
modified
next
and
change the name here you notice that i
receive an error
and that's because that name already
exists tableau won't allow you to use
the same name
and it will give you that error so those
errors can be pretty helpful in finding
out what's going on hit apply
and okay and then double click rank
modified by sales
and now we can see
the difference here
let's go back here and
look at what it says here click on ring
modified and it says it returns the
modified competition rank where
identical values are assigned an
identical rank
but
what happens instead
is instead of both receiving three
for third place
they both receive four
which is the lower of the options so if
we were going by rank and we just
arbitrarily decided that this one's
third place and this one's fourth place
then they both receive the same ring
here but they receive the higher of the
two options whereas this one receives
the lower of the two options
and let's do one more
duplicate
edit
erase copy
and we're going to do
rank
unique
and let's change the name
to rank unique
perfect and now this is going to give it
a unique
ranking even when they share the same
number so we'll hit apply
okay double click rank unique
and we have one two
three four and five
so what it's doing is let's quickly
look here so
rank by sales
we haven't talked about this yet but you
can choose to rank it ascending or
descending that means that do we want to
rank it based on
whether you see here it says ascending
or descending and that's how you will
define so it defaults to descending and
it's saying the biggest is the best so
in for sales that's accurate so what
it's doing is biggest down now here it
has to decide which one to give three
and which one to do for
and it's doing that based on the ascii
values of
the store
so it's looking at more information on
the row and since uppercase b comes
before lowercase c uppercase b is
getting the 3.
even though they both have 20 for sales
let's go back now to our orders data
and we'll make a new sheet and now we're
going to talk about actions in tableau
we've talked about actions briefly
before
in our tableau training video for
beginner so if you want to see the
introduction you can go and look there
also if you want to follow along with
our data sets you can comment below and
ask and the simply learn team will get
you that data set
so let's make a chart where we're going
to look at
category so we'll drag category onto
columns and then we're going to look at
sales so we'll drag sales onto rows and
it will create three bar charts for us
and we're going to
call this
sales by category
now let's make a second chart that we
will use together and we'll bring
category onto columns and we'll bring
subcategory onto columns
and let's bring sales
onto rows again
and let's
take
subcategory and bring it onto color and
that makes each subcategory its own
color
and we'll call this sheet
sales by subcategory
so now back to sales by category here
you can make a worksheet action
where we're going to
move from the sales by category sheet to
the sales by subcategory sheet and also
filter down that sheet to only the
category we want to see
so click filter
and we can name this filter
go to subcategory
and we're going to do this filter on
select so this name won't be seen except
for in our actions list
and what sheets do we want to affect
we're going to have
sales by category show up one thing to
note here it is only showing the sheets
for it to affect based on the ones that
are using this data source at this point
so you can see we have four sheets down
here but it's only showing three sheets
and that's because rank example if you
recall is using the rank example data
source so you can click here and you can
see all the sheets or you can see the
other
data source if we click rank example it
will show the rank example data source
so we just want sales by category to be
the source sheet
and the target sheet we want it to be
sales by subcategory
so on select we want it to be sales by
subcategory we're going to use all the
fields available
to create this filter and hit ok so now
we have our go to sub category on select
we'll hit ok again
and
let's
make this a little wider so we can see
and so when we click on furniture it
will take us to only furniture of
the sales by subcategory we go back to
category we click on office supplies now
we just see office supplies and this is
a way to make tableau drill to a lower
level
so we have those
now let's
duplicate this sales by category sheet
and let's see if we go to worksheet and
we go to
actions you can see that we have the
action here
go to subcategory that still exists on
our duplicated sheet as well so you can
see it's affecting both sheets sales by
category and sales by category 2. let's
say we don't want that and we can
unselect sales by category two
and hit okay
and hit okay
now when we go to worksheet actions
you can tell that it's not affecting
that sheet so if we come and click
technology nothing should happen but we
go to sales by category and click
technology it'll take you to the
technology subcategory
great so we have our sales by category
two let's bring it to the end
rename it
we're going to call it sales by category
stacked
because we're going to take subcategory
here and drag it onto
color and now we can see our different
subcategories
in the colors there
now we can take a look
here
and sort by
subcategory based on some of sales
and now you can see that
it is the biggest sales at the bottom
for each sub category that's just
a way that i like to view it so
let's do a highlight action and we're
going to do it on a dashboard
so let's take
sales by
subcategory
and look at it over top of our sales by
category stacked over top of sales by
sap category so we want both of those
let's make our
dashboard automatic for
testing purposes
and we'll go to dashboard we'll click
create actions so we're going to add an
action it's going to be a highlight
action
highlight sales by
subcategory
and we are going to have the sales by
category stacked be the source sheet and
the sales by subcategory be the target
sheet for all fields okay
okay and on select you can highlight
your chart there
and see where it falls inside of the
other visualization
a cool thing you can do is you could
select office supplies here and it will
highlight all of office supplies or if
you drag and select a couple of them it
will show you those so you're just like
i want to see all these small ones or i
want to see this one and these small
ones or whatever then it will highlight
the ones that you drag and select now
this is also true of our sales by
subcategory and sales by category so
when we clicked on technology it
filtered to just technology
and we'll undo that and when we drag and
click
office supplies and technology we get
office supplies and technology now if we
go back to the dashboard we can see that
this dashboard is now filtered also to
office supplies and technology and
that's because we're using the same
sheet
and when you navigate away from that
sheet it doesn't mean that your filter
goes away
so when i clicked undo
that's when it caused the filter to go
away so
if you're going to have two
things affect that sheet
just remember that just because you
navigated away from what you selected
doesn't mean that what you selected goes
away that filter will stay there if it
shows up right here
and if we pull it off everything goes
back to normal however the action is
still there so when you click on it it
comes back
now let's take a look at the last kind
of action which is a url action
so we're going to make a map based on
state so i'm going to double click state
and it's going to build out my map let's
change it to a field
map
by clicking map up here
and we're going to take sales and put it
onto color
so now it's colored based on the darkest
is the highest sales
we're going to put state onto label so
you can see the state name and we're
going to put sales onto label
so we can see the sales amount let's
quickly
change our default property for sales
so that it always shows up as currency
and we're going to
lose the decimal places so it'll by
default show up with a dollar sign and
so on
great so now we have our sales map and
we're going to create
a worksheet action now the difference
between a worksheet action and a
dashboard action is that a worksheet
will only affect the worksheet and the
dashboard will only affect the dashboard
and so when we created our worksheet
action on sales by category if we were
to pull sales by category onto the
dashboard that action won't transfer
over you'll need to make a dashboard
action
so we're going to make a go to url
action we're going to have it on menu
we're going to call it wiki
and it's going to only affect our new
sheet
sheet 6 which we should rename and we're
going to have a url in here so this will
take us to wikipedia and then whatever
you put at the end of the wikipedia link
it will take you to that page on
wikipedia so
we're going to take state and add it to
the end of that link
and now to test the link you can just
click test link
and it will take a random value and show
you what it will look like so now that's
how we know that we have our link set up
okay click ok let's rename our sheet to
url
filter by state
and so when we click on texas okay back
to url filter by state let's go to our
worksheets
and go to our actions and on the go to
sub category
it is also affecting this url filter by
state because we didn't unselect it now
to keep that from being a problem we're
going to just come here and sales by
category be the only sheet and that way
it won't auto select no sheets as you
create them
so we'll no longer have that problem you
click on texas and nothing happens
except for it highlights that one only
that's how it should be but when we
hover on texas and wait long enough oh
yeah on click sometimes you just have to
hold still it'll come up with our little
link here and we click on wiki and it
will open up
our browser with the wikipedia page for
texas this can become really handy in
the event that you have data that maybe
has an order id and you can take that
order id and insert it into a url in
your system so that it can take you to
your web interface page for that order
here it's helpful for if we wanted to
learn more about the state of california
which
it can have information about the
languages spoken
and population
which can be helpful when we're looking
into our sales information
another way this can be useful is by
showing the webpage right inside of
tableau so let's make a dashboard
change our size to automatic and let's
pull in url filter by state
if we go to dashboard actions you can
see there are no actions for this
dashboard yet so we're going to add a go
to url action on select
and since it's on select the name of
this url won't
show up
but it will show up in our list here so
it's nice to name it something unique
let's put in our wikipedia page and
it'll take us to state so we'll hit okay
okay and now when we click on oklahoma
it'll open up a page for oklahoma
but let's unselect oklahoma if we drag
on web page from the objects here
you don't even have to enter anything
for your url you just hit ok and now we
have the bottom half of the screen is a
web page and when we click on oklahoma
instead of taking us to oklahoma in a
separate thing it'll take us to oklahoma
right here
in the visualization so we'll change it
to texas and this will change to texas
if you unselect it leaves the page there
based on the one that you had just
selected
next we're going to take a look at
reference bands and lines so let's make
a new sheet
and we're going to call it
reference
lines and so a reference line is found
on the analytics pane
and it is something that comes and draws
a line on your visualization based on
the data on the screen so
let's make our visualization we'll do
our category
and sub category again
and we'll double click on sales
and it brings it onto text that's not
what i want so let's do sales onto rows
and we have our bar charts
and
we'll talk about the difference between
a cell a pane and the table so when we
go to analytics
and we go to drag our reference line
onto
our visualization it says you can add
the reference line for the whole table
for a pane or for a cell
so
if we
take our subcategory and drag it onto
color
since the subcategory is our lowest
level it's going to define our cell
so each one of these if we drag our
reference line onto
so
each one of them gets a reference line
you see how it added those on this is
our dialog box we will look at that in
just a moment
so let's remove that if we take
reference line and put it onto pane
that's going to be similar to have a
category on the color so each of these
different colors
is now a pain
reference line onto pane and you see how
we get reference lines
based on each pane
so let's undo that
and now if we take category off and
everything is all one color and we take
reference line and put it onto table
now we have our reference line for the
whole table
great so we're going to do
find out the average for each
section
so i'm going to take category put it
back onto color and we'll take reference
line and put it onto pain
now we have our reference line it's
based on the computation of average
and it's using the value of sum of sales
so since it says sum of sales here you
might think that it was taking the cut
reference line and putting it at the sum
of the sales but that's not what's
happening it's just using our aggregated
version of sales to figure out the
average so instead of taking each
individual sale
that makes up the bookcase section it's
taking the sum of sales for the bookcase
section and comparing it to the sum of
sales for chairs
so it's taking an average across these
added up sections
we could also have it be total
where it's adding all of these up and it
makes that total line
the sum line is the same as total in
this case
a constant which is where you get to
define the value and so if we wanted it
to be 200
thousand there it is
let's go back
there we are back to where we were
constant minimum which shows you the
minimum for each section
the maximum for each section
or the average
or the median so let's stick with
average and now you can see it's
labeling the line as average we could
also have it label the line as the value
so now we can see that the average is
this amount of dollars
or you can choose custom and then you
can put something in here
like maybe we wanted the computation a
colon
and then the value average
this amount
you can also have a show recalculated
line for highlighted or selected data
points that means when you click on a
section it will recalculate the average
just for what you've selected we'll hit
ok
and so in that case when we click on
tables
you can see our
recalculated
average line
so the average for tables for just
tables
is the sum divided by the number so the
sum of tables is 206 966 divided by one
is still 206 966 so selecting just
tables is really helpful but if we
wanted to know the average of
tables and we'll control click
appliances
and we'll control click binders oh there
we go
all three of those are selected we can
see the average of those three which is
this line
you could also select like this
and see your new average
oh and it's doing the average
independently so
select these guys and now we see the
average of just those
five categories and those are reference
lines
now let's duplicate this sheet
and i'll show you how to delete a
reference line
so we'll rename this to reference
bands click on this reference line
right click and click remove and it
takes it off we have the same thing for
reference bands we had with reference
lines where you can have it be for the
whole table per pane or per cell so
let's do a reference band for the whole
table so it's doing entire table
and it's taking from the minimum to the
maximum now we could change the minimum
to be the average to the maximum and now
that will highlight the whole table
everything that's above the average
becomes highlighted
and if you wanted to change it you could
do the minimum to the average
but let's go to
average to
maximum and then you can change things
like you can add lines so we have a line
for the average or the maximum you can
make it thinner you can make it dotted
you can change your fill so maybe if you
don't want it to be quite that dark you
can change it to be a little bit of a
lighter color of gray
and you can have show recalculated band
for highlighted or you can remove that
and that way when we highlight stuff
everything just stays where it belongs
for the entire table
and that's how you create a reference
band
reference bands and reference lines can
be really handy in making
several different kinds of
visualizations such as bullet charts
if you have any questions about that
please comment below and the simply
learn team will get back to you now
let's do another analysis on average
days to ship
and for this one we're going to
look at it by state
and we're going to look at it by
ship mode
and so we'll take average stasis ship
and put it on columns
and now we can see
the average days to ship by first class
same day second class or standard class
and you can see
how they differ so let's
change the order of these really quick
if we come up here to ship mode and we
click sort and we click manual we can
have same day above first class so that
it kind of goes in order of priority so
same day first class second class
standard class
there we go and now we have it in
order of what you might expect and
priority and now we're going to create a
calculated field that we will use to do
a sort of conditional formatting
and we will name it delay analysis
great so let's do
if
the
average days ship
is less than or equal to two
then
we'll have it return the words
shipment early
so if we want to press enter there that
won't cause any problems to our
calculation so you can press enter you
could have extra spaces and it won't uh
tableau will ignore those so this allows
us to format our calculated field in a
way that's easy to read so if it's less
than two then they're going to call it
an early shipment
else if
average days to ship is greater than or
equal to five
then shipment
late
and
else if let's get the rest of them
and
average days of ship is
not less than two
greater than two
and less than
five
then
on time
two words
on time
and now you can see we have an error
here
it says expected end to match if that
means that we don't have an end
at the end of our if statement
if statements always have to have an end
okay let's hit apply
and let's grab our delay analysis and
put it on to color
and it has on time as blue
early shipment
as orange
and shipment linked as red we can double
click on the color and we can change
shipment early to green
and now we can see
the best ones the on time ones and the
ones that stand out as late and standard
class happens late a lot it's
interesting to see that on average the
district of columbia
has second class as a legit late
shipment you can see that all of these
share
the same axis size so they all go from
zero to six
even though this one never gets that
close to six
if we click edit axis
you can choose if you want that to be
the case so it's like right now all of
them use uniform access range for all
rows and columns and that's really nice
because it's easy to compare
colorado to colorado to colorado if you
change it to independent access for each
rose you can see now this one only goes
from zero to not even one whereas this
one goes from zero to six
and you can compare it with color but
you can no longer compare it with size
across all of these different categories
so uniform access range is the default
in this case
and we will keep it that way
so now we have a quick analysis of our
delays
we're now going to build a waterfall
chart
based on profit
so we'll call this our profit
waterfall
and um we'll take a look at what a
waterfall
looks like at the end and talk about how
it works
so after we build it we'll talk about
some of the benefits of having a
waterfall chart so what we're going to
do is build it over time for this
visualization we're just going to look
at the year of 2014 so i'm going to
filter it to the order dates for 2014
and then we're going to take our order
date and bring it onto columns and we're
going to look at it by month but we're
going to look at it by
our discrete month
so you can see that i chose the one that
has month and year
and then when i chose discrete
and then we're going to take profit and
put it onto rows and we're going to
change it from
profit
to
our
running total of profit
so you can see that it takes january and
then it adds february to it
and so it's always getting bigger when
we undid it sometimes there's up and
down
so
back to we only have our running total
where it will some january and february
for the february mark and then some
january february march for the march
mark if i take profit
and put it here you can see january is
negative three thousand and february is
positive two thousand but here it's the
sum of those which is negative 467.
take that back off we're going to change
our marks to a gaunt bar
and now we're going to
duplicate profit
and edit what we have
we're going to call this negative profit
and it's going to be just profit
with the negative sign in front
oh it looks like i've done this before
so
now we have a new name because i added a
space at the end so hit apply
and let's delete the old one
okay so now we have our negative profit
just to look at it it's just minus
profit
and we're going to use that to determine
the size
of the gaunt bar so
what it does
is it takes where the line was and it
adds the size of it to be the size of
profit but because the line was at the
top and we didn't want to build the
profit up we had to change it to
negative profit so it would build it
down so here the line was down here
because it was so low negative and we
added negative profit and then let's
take profit and put it on color
and so you can see where profit is
negative it turns it orange
and my profit is positive it turns it
blue so what's happening here what we
can do now is we can see our total sales
at the end and how we got there so for
the first month we were at zero when we
started and we went down to negative
three thousand the next month we were at
negative three thousand when we started
and it grew up to be almost back to zero
and then we can see that from there on
out we grew up
each month and you can see how much each
month contributed
our biggest contributors are november
and march november being a little bit
bigger
and you can see where we started at the
beginning of that month and where we
ended and that's how a waterfall chart
works so it lets you go through over
time and see exactly where our problems
were
and exactly which months helped the most
where we started and where we ended for
each month
next we're going to talk about level of
detail calculation and we'll talk about
those first by showing an example
so i'm going to bring all my customers
on
by name and then i'm going to bring on
order id
and it's going to add all members but
then i'm going to change order id
from a dimension to
a measure and we have account distinct
so now we can see each customer and how
many
orders they have so let's sort it and we
can see
one person has 17 orders and we have
1 2
3 4
5 6 7
people have 13 orders
and it goes on from there
so what if we wanted to make a
visualization that would show
how many customers
had how many orders and what
number of orders was the most popular
we would need to do a level of detail
calculation so let's clear the workbook
a level of detail calculation allows you
to build a visualization
and bring on metrics that are at a level
that is different from what's shown on
the visualization
so
in order to do this
we need to
create a calculated field
that will show us
the number of orders per customer
even though we're not going to have our
visualization be per customer
so let's call this orders
per customer
and we'll come here and we're going to
use a level of detail calculation called
fixed
now there are
two other level of detail calculations
and they are called include
and exclude
and you can learn more about those
in
some of our simply learn classes and if
you have any questions please comment
below and we can answer them so we're
going to do it fixed and you can choose
dimensions and it computes an
aggregation using only the specified
dimensions
so it will ignore all the other
dimensions and we're going to have it
based on customer name
so we're going to have fixed customer
name
and we're going to call
get account distinct
of order id
and make sure you close it with your
curly bracket and we have no errors and
we'll hit ok
and this allows us to see number of
orders per customer so
let's pull it out
first let's make it a dimension
and then pull it out onto our columns
and now we can see
one two three four five six seven eight
up to 17. so that means we had
some customers just order one and some
customers ordered 17 and we had them
order everything in between so if we
never had a customer that had nine
orders
then nine wouldn't appear in this list
now we're going to take customer
id or name
let's do id because it should be unique
and we'll pull it onto roast and we're
going to change it to a measure
and it's going to be
account distinct
and so now we can see
how many customers ordered
how many items
so we have our number of orders per
customer which is at the per customer
level even though this visualization is
not at the per customer level
there's nowhere in this visualization
where we pull on the customer
item as a dimension
so let's sort it biggest smallest
and we can see that 134 of our customers
ordered five items or had five orders
and so it just five is the most popular
seven is the next most popular 17 is the
least popular one is relatively
unpopular which is interesting to know
and so you can use this to analyze how
many items your customers generally
order
and maybe if they have four items
that they are going to order that
perhaps if you made good suggestions you
could get them to go up to five
and that's an introduction to level of
detail
so let's name this sheet
level of detail lod
orders per
customer
perfect
now let's make a new sheet
and we are going to
do an analysis about new customers
so we'll call this level of detail new
customer
analysis
so this visualization is going to be
about customer acquisition over time so
when we do things over time we grab our
date and pull it up here and for a line
chart or anything over time
we're going to
use these
so that it makes an axis
instead of just
change to line
instead of dimensions or something that
is not continuous and then we're going
to take our customer id
pull it onto rows but let's change it to
[Music]
account distinct customer id and now we
can see our count of customers on every
day i think day is too low of a level
let's go ahead and month
so now we can see how many customers
made an order during what month
let's take region
and split it out by region
when we click on central we can see
central now this is including all
customers
but say we only wanted to include a
customer when they're making their very
first order
so we're only going to include their
first order so we need to create a
calculated field
and we want to compare
we'll call it new or existing
and we want to compare their order date
per customer
to their first order date the min
order date
nope
order date
and we're going to get this error it
says cannot mix aggregate which is min
and non-aggregate functions and what
it's saying here is that
this order date is at a per row level
since we don't have any aggregation on
it and this order date is at a per
visualization level so it's only going
to split up based on
the visualization and it won't let you
put those two things together so we're
going to
use our level of detail calculation
again
and we're going to make this fixed per
customer id
and then we'll do our min
order date
so now instead of
trying to return something different
based on the visualization it will
always return the min for each customer
id
so if the order date on the
visualization is equal to this order
date
if the order date on the visualization
is equal to the first order date for
that customer
then
new
else existing
end
so
when the order date equals the very
first order date that means that it's a
new
customer making their first order
otherwise it's an existing customer
because it's no longer their earliest
date
apply
okay and now we can take our new field
which is new or existing and drag it
onto filters and we only want new
we'll hit apply
and we can see that we have new
customers
but
less over time
so
so now we're going to change this
count distinct
to be a running total and we can see
over time
how
our new customers are adding up so it's
taking the prior value and adding our
new customers and then at the end we get
our total customers for each
region and we can now make this a more
the lowest level which is day
and you can see
places where it like levels out so we
can see we have a lot of new customers
and it's increasing but then here for
the region of east there kind of is a
level spot where we're not getting new
orders
and that seems to be the same for each
of them so for february of 2014 why were
we not getting any new orders
and how come the west region is getting
new customers how come the west region
is getting new customers faster here
while it's leveling out in the red
it looks like the west region
leveled out as well but picked up sooner
and started getting new customers
so this type of analysis will help you
view
new customers over time and it's only
possible because we were able to do a
level of detail calculation
here on new or existing
that would compare
this data at
only aggregating the data for the
specified dimension
so we were able to grab their minimum
order date here
so those are a couple of ways that level
of detail calculations can be very
helpful
in summary today we learned about
live versus extract tableau
data sources we learned about joins and
unions in the data sources we also
looked at table versus database
calculations we looked at how the
different ranks compare
we built some actions into our
dashboards filter actions and
highlighting actions we also looked at
url actions we built dashboards that
used reference lines and ones that used
reference bands we did analyzing of
average days to ship
and delay analysis
we built a waterfall chart
and we also looked into some level of
detail calculations today we will be
building dashboards from start to finish
first about world population then health
next we'll build a dashboard about
economy and finally we'll build a
dashboard about business ease i would
recommend getting access to the data set
before you start this tutorial so you
can build along with me if you would
like access to this data set please
comment below and we'll get you access
so first we're going to build a
dashboard that revolves around
population so we're going to build
a map based on country so i'm going to
double click on country and it's going
to map out all the countries and then on
our marks i'm going to change it to map
so it's a filled in map and we want this
to be colored by population total
and we can see
who contributes the most to population
we're going to label it with population
as well
but you can see that it's labeling it
the total population and what we want to
label it is
how much it contributes to population by
percentage so let's add a table
calculation and we're going to have it
do percent of total
based on country
okay so now we can see which countries
contribute what percent
let's also bring the country name onto
the label
and
let's put it on top so country names on
top now it's getting a little bit of
crowded in here so
we're going to un click show marks label
and we're just going to show the ones
that
we want to see specifically so we can
right click on china here hover on mark
label and click always show
and on india
since these are our two biggest
contributors
we can see that this one's a little bit
darker than the others in that area
and here
here
and that's just a manual way to choose
which ones have indicators labels and
which ones do not
and we're going to put a note here so
we're going to annotate
an area
that explains that
china and india
contribute the most to world population
just calling out
this section of the visualization
and let's name this sheet
so here we have our visualization and
when you hover you can see both the
total population and its percent
contribution and the country name
our next visualization for this
dashboard is going to be
population over time
so
[Music]
let's bring on our time element but one
trick for bringing on a time element if
we just drag it on so year with the
calendar mark here if we just drag it on
it'll default
to
a discrete version so let's take it back
off
and then we could edit it there but one
thing you could do is if you on
a windows machine you right click on it
and drag it on then it will pop up
with a dialog box that allows you to
select what kind of
date value you want to use in the first
place so we're going to use year here
and now we have instead of discrete we
have a continuous axis
and we're going to bring on
population total
and we can see that over time one thing
you can do when the value is up so high
in your axis is you can uncheck this box
that says include zero and it will
not always include zero on your axis but
this can be misleading so you can see
that it looks like population growth is
something really dramatic by increasing
that slope of the line
whereas it really wasn't quite as
dramatic as it seems so as long as it's
communicated
well and you're not doing it to mislead
your users
you just need to keep in mind that this
includes zero can change what your graph
is saying so we're going to
not include the zero at this time
just so that we can focus in on our data
a little bit
now we're going to add our forecast so
we're going to click on forecast and
drag it on
and it adds the forecast to our
visualization right there and now we can
right click here
and see forecast result is
actual and forecast
so you can see that the forecast picks
up
here in 2012 and pushes out what it
thinks it'll be in 2013 as well you can
change how far out that forecast goes by
right clicking on the line and clicking
forecast option
and we can change as is automatically
the next two years but we could change
it so that it's the next 10 years and it
will go out into the future
out to 2022
you can change prediction intervals or
if you don't want to show them you don't
have to show them and this is just kind
of
a visual guide for those prediction
intervals
okay and then you can also
have your trend line show
where it shows your trend line following
out from where your population growth
is and also the trend line for your
forecast right there
and we'll call this
world population
trend
excellent and we're going to make one
more visualization for this and it's
going to be a pie chart so the pie chart
is also going to be based off of
population
so we're going to click on population
and we're going to control click on
country and come over to show me
and click your pie chart
great so i'm going to make this
the entire view so we can see the pie
chart better
and this is getting really crazy in here
and so i have changed my mind and
instead of country i'm going to drag
region over top of country and now we
see something a little bit more
manageable so we can see that here's
asia
and it makes up
the biggest piece of the pie and then
here is everybody else so right now
each of these is population total
and we could keep it that way or we
could
do what we did last time
and change it to percent of total
so that on hover we can see
the population and
the percentage of population that it
contributes
so for this pie chart we're just going
to
show asia versus everybody else so we
need to make a group and what we'll do
is
select all of these
and we're going to right click and click
group
so now we have
all those things we selected and we have
other let's edit our group right click
edit group
we're going to
rename this group
asia because
that's all that's in there and we're
going to rename this group
rest of the world
okay
so now we have our group we can drag it
onto label and we can see asia and rest
of the world and now see how it's
breaking it up into those different
sections that's because we still have
region on
our
detail right here so we pull region off
now let's just split asia rest of the
world
we can change our colors
make it a little bit more
visually interesting
now we can still see our percentages
and now let's rename it and then we'll
put it all together on a dashboard
great so let's make our dashboard we
have this new dashboard button down here
and you can choose what sizes you want
so we have a fixed size where you just
select the width and height we have
automatic which will just fill your
screen
and
we have a range which has a minimum size
and a maximum size
some of the
good things about fixed is that once you
have it you can have it always look that
way so no matter where they're looking
at it you know that it's going to be
laid out the way that you expected
however if somebody's looking out on a
screen that is bigger or smaller than
yours then it doesn't fill up the screen
or it will fill the screen too much and
they'll have to scroll up and down and
left and right
if you have automatic then it will fit
the screen that it's displayed on
however the things that you've placed
might get squished too close together
and then the range gives you a minimum
size and a maximum size meaning if the
screen is too big
it still won't fill up the screen but it
can get closer and then as they get
smaller and smaller screens
you at least know that it will never
make it get smaller than this particular
size so there's some benefits to that as
well where you still have a little bit
of control of what it will look like in
the end
great let's bring on our worksheets
and you can see that where you hover
it fills up that space and that's where
it's going to show up you can also
adjust the lines in between different
visualizations for things that need more
space or less space
another important thing to recognize is
that when you click on a visualization
like this one up here it will tell you
how it's viewing that visualization
within that space so if you click
standard then it will do a standard fit
versus if you have entire view where it
will
make it fit into inside the box over
here we could have fit width
or fit height
on some of the visualizations it doesn't
make as much of a difference however
when you have a visualization that maybe
has a lot of text in it and they need to
be able to scroll you'll want to have it
fit width but you don't want it to fit
height because then it will shove all of
that information
into the box and not allow you to scroll
up and down
so as you saw as we dragged these on it
took
these
legends and added it to the left here
we can modify that
and make them floating
and drag them next to the visualizations
that they
are relevant to
and
this particular one
has a couple of things wrong with it we
might not want the title of this to be
region group
so we could come in and we could edit
the title and then
maybe just call it region
however i don't think we need this
legend at all because it's very clearly
marked on the visualization there so you
could also just remove it from the
dashboard
and this
one is telling you how big of a circle
it would need to be before it gets to
that population number so
it belongs to this circle as well but
again
is unnecessary
potentially because we have our two
population numbers
showing up right as we hover
so we remove that as well so at this
point we have a visualization or three
visualizations all on the same page
which is the basics of a dashboard
however we might want to be able to
interact with them a little bit more
than just hovering
and so this is where we should look into
adding filters so we have information
over time we have information by country
and we have some information by region
here
one of the quickest things you can do to
add functionality to the dashboard is by
clicking this uses filter button so if
we click this that means whatever
country we click on here
will filter the other visualization
and then you can unselect it
to go back
now
that uses filter button
actually creates an action here
filter one generated that it's made on
its own now you can see that when we
click on
china
it doesn't make a lot of sense to have
this pie chart update based on that
china click because it's just going to
show
duplicated information so it shows the
20
or the 20 percent here and the 17
billion and then here it does the same
thing except for it shows 100 because
it's filtered everything else out of the
chart so it now makes up 100 of the
circle so that doesn't make a lot of
sense
so there are ways to format your
visualization or your actions
modify your actions so that they only
affect the things that make sense so we
can come here and click edit
we're going to call this country
action
and we want it to
use the population by country sheet and
then modify
only the trend
so now when we click on
china we see china's trend over time and
it doesn't affect our pie
because that doesn't make sense for it
to affect our pie
we might want to select on our pie
asia or rest of the world and have that
affect the other visualization so we can
click use this filter here and click
asia
and now it zooms into asia on our map
and shows us just the asia world
population trend and here's rest of the
world and we can see that asia is grayed
out
and there's the rest of the world and
here's the rest of the world population
trend
we might also want to be able to use
this to filter to a certain year so if
we click use this filter
then we click on
2011
you can see these numbers are slightly
updating so this is 19
and we come here 19.5 percent
come down here and we can see that the
pi updates a little bit
although it hasn't been anything
dramatic
you can kind of see it over time
so that's one way
to add filters to your visualization
another way
is to use actual filtering instead of
just actions so if we come back here to
our trend
we could take the year we're going to
control click and drag it onto filters
and now we have a year filter so we
could have it the actual year number so
just look at one year at a time or a
range of dates
so if we click range of dates that makes
this slider
from 2000 to 2012. so if we hit ok
we'll right click and we'll click show
filter we can see it here and as we drag
this
it updates
but kind of messes with our forecast
so let's not do a year filter
in this case
so we could remove filter there
but maybe we want a filter just on this
for the different years
so let's drag year on to the filters
we're just going to do the year number
next and here's all the years we're
going to let all them be selected for
now
and then we're going to show the filter
and here's all of our years
and we can change the way that our quick
filter shows up
and we can make it like a drop down so
they can still select multiples but it's
a drop down or maybe we want this
visualization to be just one year at a
time so we can choose single value in a
list and it lists out all the years or
in a drop down
and we want it to be
2012. and
then we want this to show up on our
dashboard so we come to the dashboard
and we click more options here hover
over filters and we can see the filters
available and we can click year of year
and now our formatting hasn't passed on
so that's one thing to remember that
formatting it just on the workbook
doesn't necessarily mean that the
formatting will pass over to the
dashboard so i tend to not do any
formatting on the workbooks and just
format it on the dashboards because the
dashboards are what i publish
so we're in a single value drop down
we're going to
[Music]
add it we're going to move it to the top
so now how we do that
let's talk a little bit about what each
of these sections are
come here to layout
and you can see we have this layout here
item hierarchy so tiled is the whole
screen and inside of that we have a
horizontal
container
and inside this horizontal container
we have another horizontal container and
when you click on something in this view
it shows you where it exists
so we can see this horizontal container
is outlined now and then we change it to
vertical and it outlines this now a
horizontal container allows things to be
side by side
and a vertical container allows things
to be a one on top of the other and so
in our vertical container we see all
this extra space for extra things to be
on top of each other but if we wanted to
have it at the top
we would maybe want things to be able to
be side by side so if we go back to the
dashboard and we grab horizontal and
drag it to the top
it adds a horizontal container up here
and now you can see everything that's
floating kind of stays in the place that
it was
even though all the other things shifted
that's one of the disadvantages of
floating is that you're kind of just
manually choosing
where it will stand
using your x and y position
and it's not dynamic
so let's give us a little bit less space
up here
we can add a text box into
our horizontal container
and we will say
population dashboard
we can format it
now we have our title up here and then
we can add our filter
we're going to drag it to be on
inside of our horizontal container but
on the
side here
you can give it more or less space
let's bring
our legends down to places where they
make sense again
perfect and so now
we have this that will affect this
only
and show you just 2012
2011 2010. so we don't want it to affect
the trend because we want the trend to
show
all of time and just looking at one year
for this trend that is only at a yearly
part and forecasts into the future
doesn't make any sense but we maybe
wanted to also affect this worksheet so
that these two are in sync
and so the dashboard is basically for
2012 except for the trend which shows
you the past in the future so one way
that you can do that is clicking apply
to worksheets here
and you can choose selected worksheets
and it will show you all the worksheets
in this visualization
or in this dashboard and you can click
show all worksheets in workbook and then
if there were other worksheets it would
show them
so we wanted to do asia versus rest of
the world and population contribution by
country
okay and that's another way we can
change what year they show so it's only
going to show one year at a time
unless we select all
and then this visualization isn't
affected by it
if we don't want
to
click on a country and have it
make the change if we instead want to
have a filter for country we can do that
by taking country and dragging it onto
filters
we'll have it show all for now
and then when we go back to our
dashboard and we come to this
visualization we can go filters and add
country
and it's just added it side by side
where we had our other filters so that's
a nice
feature of tableau where it can kind of
guess where you might want things we're
going to do multiple value drop down and
right now
it only affects that visualization and
we can just look at one country at a
time
and we might not want it to affect this
visualization because it doesn't do us
any good to just look at one region in a
pie chart
but maybe we wanted to affect the world
population trend so we can do the same
thing we did before
and we wanted to affect these two
we'll click ok
and so now
we could look at
all these countries
and that would update both these
visualizations
another thing i like to do
on a filter
is customize and click show apply button
and this means we can make all these
changes in here
see i've selected none however these
visualizations aren't updating and then
i wanted to look at turkey so i found
turkey and then i hit apply and that's
when they update
perfect so now we have a dashboard
complete with filters and
actions
we also have a title on our dashboard we
can give it a little bit less space and
some legends
we have titles on each of these pieces
however if we didn't want a title here
we can click hide title and it will just
show our visualization there and this is
dashboard number one
here's what it looks like in full screen
mode full screen mode is a good
opportunity for you to test it to see
what it will look like to the end user i
press escape and get back out
and it doesn't give you these highlights
when you hover over things that are
dashboard formatting related
you can see that all those extra lines
went away
and it just gives you the opportunity to
test out your dashboard in a more real
way and see how they will use it
instead of giving you the dashboard
editing options
next we're going to make a dashboard
revolving around health information
so first we're going to make
a map about birth rates so we're going
to call it
birth rate
rank
and to make a map we're going to double
click on country
and
we're going to change it to a map type
so we have a filled map here and then
we're going to bring birth rate onto
color
so let's define our colors a little bit
by clicking on this color part of the
marks card we'll click edit colors and
we're going to change it
to
red and gold
and the idea here is that the red is for
a higher birth rate which is
more associated with countries that have
poor health so we'll hit apply
and now we have our
higher birth rate countries highlighted
in red next we're going to create
a class so we're going to duplicate
birth rate
and let's edit that field
we're going to call it birth rate class
and so we're going to say that anything
that is in the top 50 countries
with the highest birth rate is
categorized as having
an alarming birth rate so we will
first do the average
birth rate
and then we're going to
do a rank
on that
so you see sometimes
when you're auto completing your
statements
it will replace
one of these functions that you have
with the one that you pressed tab for so
if i type if or i start to type if and
then i come here and click on if it
replaced my rank with if so keep an eye
out for that if you're like where did my
thing go it's because i was typing it
right next to it so if i put a space and
then i start to type if and i click if
it will not delete rank so we're going
to say if
the rank-up average is
less than or equal to
50 so if it's in the top 50
then
alarming
birth rate
and we could take this again
is greater than 50
then
normal over 3.
always make sure you put on the end also
we didn't necessarily have to have this
else if statement
so if we had just done else normal birth
rate that would have covered all of our
bases so with these if statements just
make sure that you're always getting all
the different options
that you want but in this case
we defined both however we didn't have
to define the second calculation because
if it is not in the top 50 then it's
obviously in the bottom the rest
so we're going to hit ok
and then we're going to put birth rate
class onto label
and it's gone around and labeled
everything
and i am seeing alarming birth rate on
everything
so let's see what the problem is
so if we open this back up by right
clicking and clicking edit you can see
it says results are computed a long
table across
so we're going to click default table
calculation here and instead of compute
using automatic we're going to change it
to compute using
country we'll hit ok
and hit apply
and that didn't seem to fix it so this
is the first place i would look if it's
not doing what you would expect so
we'll put it back to automatic okay
the second place i would look is inside
of the table calculation that is created
so when we defined rank here we put a
table calculation on it so when we right
click here we get edit table calculation
and we're going to choose that we want
to do the rate based on
the specific dimension of country
so now we can see
using the logic
the calculation assistance that
we no longer have just alarming birth
rate we have normal birth rate and
alarming birth rate on our screen so we
can close this
and
we are done here but one thing you could
do
is
when we have allow labels to overlap
other marks selected then it will make
sure that
every label shows up but it gets super
crazy in there so there are some times
where the labels may overlap a little
bit and so you'll want to select this
option in our case we don't want that
and now we have a visualization
showing
birth rate map
based on rank our next visualization
is going to be about
average life expectancy
male versus female
so we're going to do
a chart across time so we're going to
click year and bring it on to columns
and we're going to change it to
this
year
in the continuous section so now we have
an axis
and
we're going to
double click on female life expectancy
up there we go double click on female
expectancy and then double click on male
life expectancy so what that did was
made us two charts one on top of the
other but we don't want that so we'll
take this off and we're going to drag
male life expectancy right onto this
axis for the female life expectancy
and what this has done is made what's
called a blended axis chart so it's not
a dual axis chart where we have another
axis over here
for the second visualization this one is
a blended axis chart so they necessarily
use the same axis and they necessarily
have the same kinds of marks so we'll
take a look and see what the difference
is there so if i were to change this to
a bar chart we would have
a bar chart for both of them and i can't
define one separately from the other
change it back to a line chart
and they're both a line chart
now if we go back to
when we just had female life expectancy
and we drag
male on next to it and we have two
charts
now we can change it to a dual axis and
we have one on top of the other however
our axes don't line up we can see at the
top here is 15k and over here it's 14k
so we're going to synchronize the axis
and you can see
one on top of the other
and
we have two marks cards so we could have
this one be a bar chart and that would
be a line chart
so that's some of the differences of
those two we're going to do a blended
axis chart so i'm going to take male and
drag it here
and we have our blended access chart and
now you can see the our scale here
is really strange so what it's doing is
it's adding up all of the life
expectancies for all the different
countries instead of averaging it so
we're going to change that by right
clicking on the measure down in this
measure values card hovering over
measure sum and we're going to change it
to average
since i only changed one of them and
they share the same axes it's really
spread out now and it almost looks like
a straight line down there and then
let's change the other
and it should get everything a little
bit more
in sync there we go so now we can see
the average life expectancy over time
which for both of them seems to be going
up
however
it seems to be higher
for females
now let's take a look at our analytics
and let's
drag on forecast
so it's forecasted out the next two
years for both line
and we'll bring on trend
onto linear
and let's change it
to a square so now we see
each individual point for the life
expectancy for females and males and we
can see what they're expected to be in
the future
and our trends
and our next visualization
is going to be a heat map
about
multiple different
measures so we'll just call it a heat
map for now
and for our heat map we're going to look
at the different countries so we'll
bring crunchy onto rows and we're going
to look at
their
birth rate
so i just double clicked on birth rate
and brought it on we're going to look at
their health expenditure percentage on
gdp so how much they spend on
gdp
so when i double clicked on it it did
what we did before where we have a
measures value card and so now whenever
we put measures on here that determines
what goes here because we have our
measure names on columns so every
measure in here their name is going to
define the name of the column and the
values define
what's in the text right here
great we're also going to bring on
infant mortality rate and
the life expectancy for females
okay
so now it has
changed these to not have decimal points
after them which is not as helpful so
we're going to
format those
and you can format it field by field so
for birth rate
we definitely want to have
decimals afterwards
as a matter of fact the birth rate is a
percentage so instead of doing a number
standard we'll just go to percentage
and now we don't need to have those
decimals afterwards we can just look at
the birth rate as a rate
and
for
percent of gdp for health expenditures
we can come click there and do the same
thing
and for infant mortality rate
okay
and to make this make a little bit more
sense we again need to change it from a
sum
to an average
and for some of these
we could
change it from a sum to an average right
inside of
the
for all of these we could change it from
a sum to an average in the default
properties
under aggregation
so it will automatically average it
whenever we bring it out
default is sum
but if we make it automatically average
then we won't have to do that again for
any other visualizations
i won't do that at this time because i
get a little bit confused sometimes when
i don't have my sum on there by default
because that's what i'm so used to
seeing by default great so we now have
a matrix
by country and by our different metrics
here and so we can
take our measure values
and drag it onto color
and we'll make our marks from automatic
to square
and it will make our heat map
now what happens with a heat map
is it colors darkly
the higher the number it is in this case
and right now it's doing it for the
whole area so one percent is obviously
much much smaller than 82 but if we
wanted to be able to look at birth rate
independently from life expectancy we
can right click on the measure values on
the color and click use separate
legends and so now we have a legend
for each one of these let's change the
colors on those legends so that we can
see them separately a little bit more
clearly
so we'll change the colors by coming
over here to each of the legends and
we'll leave one the same
but we'll change this one
and if we click edit colors you can see
our different palettes
you can see some of them just have one
color others have one color to another
color we used the
red gold before
so now you can see that one is changed
we could use
another one that goes from
green to blue
great
you can also define your own
so you can make a custom one that could
go from
light to dark and then you can choose
what color you want as your dark color
so we could pick
a lighter blue
and then we see that last one
and now with these separate color
palettes you can quickly see the
difference with birth rate and
spending on health
and that is our heat map
with
separate legends
so let's build this all into a dashboard
now
we're going to call it our health
dashboard
and for simplicity we're going to make
it automatic so it fills our screen
and then we're going to first bring on
our map
we're going to bring on our health
related map with birth rates
then we're going to bring on our
heat map
and we'll bring on our life expectancy
lines
now as we brought on all of our charts
it brought in our legends here
and we're going to move our legends up
to the top so let's add a horizontal
container
and then let's put
our legends
into the horizontal container
and let's put these ones in order so
life expectancy
oh
so birth rate is going to be over here
great now
one thing we can do is make these
smaller
well that's actually just making that
one bigger huh okay
so you would make them smaller
by making something else bigger or by
adding in a blank space
which would then
help you adjust the size
by taking up the space that you're not
using
another thing to pay attention to is
this fixed width
so once you start to drag the size on
something it no longer is dynamic
so if we unfix that width
so that it's only taking up whatever
space is left oh and that one is not
fixed with
and then we can edit the width on this
to be
even bigger
then it will squish things over to where
we would like them to be so
that's one of the ways you can add space
or make things the size you would like
them to be now let's take a look at
filters oh before we take a look at
filters i want to look at this map one
more time because i think that it would
be useful for our colors to be
a little bit more
distinct
so
one quick way to navigate to your
worksheet from your dashboard is to
click this go to sheet button
and while we're here i'm going to click
on color
edit colors and we did red and gold and
we're going to change it from
this sequence to a stepped color
and we're going to change it to three
colors so it's going to either be
this color this color this color and
when i hit ok
you can kind of see it's a little bit
more dramatic
in our differences and it's put
everything into the three categories we
defined so let's go back to our
dashboard
and we can see the difference there
and now we're going to take a look at
our filters so we want to be able to
filter by country
so let's bring country onto filters
now we're going to allow it to use all
and we're going to
here you can click apply to worksheets
and you can click selected worksheets
and it's going to pop up with all the
worksheets
in the whole workbook
and so one disadvantage of doing on the
worksheet is that you can see all of the
worksheets in the workbook and you have
to differentiate between which ones are
on the dashboard which ones aren't and
these are the three on this dashboard so
we're going to hit ok
and we're also going to do it by year so
when we drag the year onto filters
we're going to
[Music]
allow them to
choose years so we're going to do
the distinct number of years we'll click
use all
okay
and we're going to apply to the
worksheets
this one with the birth rate and the
average life expectancy male versus
female we're not going to filter down
our line chart by year
because we want to be able to see it
over time and if we filter down the time
then we don't get as much context so
we'll hit ok
let's go back to our dashboard
if i click on more options here and
hover over filters you can see that year
filter and that country filter
you should also be able to see both of
those filters on the heat map
because i told it to apply to that one
as well so here's the country oh
i made a mistake let's go back to this
visualization
and
apply to worksheets
selected worksheets
see i wanted it to be on the birth rate
and the heat map not the line chart and
i clicked the wrong one
so that was a good test
so when we go here to the heat map
and click down
you can see now
we get the year of year as well so we'll
click year of year let's put it over
here
and we're going to make it
a multiple values drop down and we'll
bring it over
to the middle
and let's also
get the countries filter
great so now that we have these in here
we don't need this to be so big so let's
edit the width and make it
300
even smaller
200
great and let's change our country
to be
a single value drop down so you can pick
one at a time and let's also change it
or this year of year since we can select
multiples let's change it so that
on customize that you show the apply
button
so here since they can only select one
we don't have the apply button because
it will just automatically apply
and here since they can select multiples
we'll let them unselect all and pick
their years
and then hit apply and then you'll see
the changes
and you can see that even though i've
selected only 2011 and 2012 you still
see all the years on this line chart as
expected
and there
is our health dashboard
our next dashboard is going to have to
do with economy
our first sheet is going to be
another map that is going to have to do
with
overall
gdp and
as we usually begin with maps by double
clicking on country
and changing it to a map mark type
and this time we're going to bring on
gdp onto color
and change it to average
and we can edit the colors
let's this time do
a custom diverging so you get to pick
both colors
and let's pick
a little bit lighter
hmm okay red for there and then we want
to do maybe like a deeper
green
and that way
you can see
who has the highest gdp which is green
we hit apply
okay
and then it will
eventually get lighter and lighter until
it goes to gray which then it will lead
to green
okay
and next we're going to make
scatter plot
which we will call
gdp versus gdp per capita
so
gdp or gross domestic product versus
gross domestic product per capita or per
person
and to make a scatter plot
you have one
measure on one axis
and then another measure which is going
to be
gdp per capita which we will now create
on the other axis
so let's start with gdp and we'll hit
duplicate
and let's edit that and we're going to
call it
gdp per capita
and we're going to take
sum
of gdp
and divided by the
sum of the total
population so population total
what is my error
opening parenthesis
there we go
and then we have gdp per capita so let's
what this will do is sum up the gdp
across whatever measures we have in
place go across whatever dimensions we
have in place and then sum up the
population for those same dimensions and
then divide it instead of dividing it
per row
and then
doing an aggregation on it
okay
so now we're going to bring on gdp per
capita on the rows
and we have the sum of gdp and the gdp
per capita and to make it more than just
one
little mark on our scatter plot we will
drag on country to detail and now we
have one mark per
country
and you can see some countries have
a high gdp per capita
and some countries have a high gdp
overall but not as high of a gdp per
capita
and so on we have some middle of the
road people here so we can change this
from automatic
to circles and now they're
dots like you might see on scatter plot
and you can
drag region
onto
color
and now we can see our different regions
and see we see a lot of reds here
and
it's quick to see
what region things belong in also you
can click to highlight and you can see
all of the americas highlighted in
context
the next visualization we're going to
make
is going to be
showing how much countries spend on
health care
as a part of their gdp so
we're going to rename it
to be gdp on healthcare
and we're going to look at each of our
countries
and we're going to make a bar chart
that shows
the health expense gdp
and we're going to change this to
average
and we're also going to show
the health expense per capita
over here it shows how much is spent per
person on health
and
this
is showing how much
is spent on health
based on gdp
click at the top and click sort and it's
sorting by this first one
and you can see which countries spend
the most of their gdp on health
we can again bring region under color so
we can see the different
regions
highlighted
and
let's bring on labels
so for our different marks cards
we're going to want to control click
this
and drag it onto the labels
and we can see that it's a percentage
but it's coming up as a number so
we can right click and click
format right there
and
we're going to change the number to
percentage
maybe just do one decimal place
and then for this one
we're going to control
and drag
that onto labels
and maybe we'll change this one to
currency
however if you don't want to change it
to currency
since we aren't sure
necessarily what currency this data set
is in it's worth checking out
what currency it is in
so for now we'll just have it as a
number
and now we're going to
customize our tool tip
so we're going to go to the overall
marks card
and we'll click on tool tip and we want
it to tell us the country in the top so
a race region
and we're going to
erase country label and center country
and then we're going to put
this country
spends
this percentage
on
healthcare
and if you want to preview it you can
hover or click here on preview and it
will show you an example marshall island
spends 2.1 percent on healthcare we'll
hit enter and then when we hover
it tells you the country and it has our
custom tool tip on both visualizations
or on both
of the different axes
so
let's build our dashboard
we'll bring on our map
we'll bring on our
healthcare
visualization
and our gdp versus gdp per capita
and we'll move our legends to the top
again
by adding a horizontal container to the
top
and bringing them up here
one thing we can do also
is to give this more space
we can have it go all the way to the top
and these legends are just side by side
just above the map
and the gdp per capita
scatter type plot
an interesting thing you can do in
tableau is you can see this outlier of
the united states is making it difficult
to see the rest of the information or to
visualize if there's any trend there
so you could right click on it and click
exclude
and then it will exclude it from your
data set very quickly
and then you'll just click this back
button to get it back
great now let's take a look at filters
we are going to do a single filter
so let's go to this visualization and
we'll bring on country
we'll click use all
okay
now we're going to apply it to
worksheets so i showed you how we can
apply it to worksheets here
you can also apply it to worksheets once
it's on the dashboard so if we come here
and look at filters we can see the
countries on the filters for this
visualization
but if we come down here
and look at filters
we still see country because it's in the
details of the information so
either way when we add country
since i added it from this visualization
it only affects this visualization
okay
but we want it to affect all on the
worksheet
so we're going to apply to worksheets
and we can click selected worksheets and
we can click all on dashboard
okay
let's bring this over here we're going
to allow them to see all at once and be
able to scroll and select the ones they
want and now
when we select different ones it affects
all three worksheets
we're also going to add an action
for a url action add action go to url
and when we click on a country on the
overall gdp map we want it to take us to
the wikipedia page that talks about the
economy for that country
so that is
this url and it's going to say wikipedia
for economy of
and we're going to add our country to
the end
so we hit ok
we have it running on menu so let's
change it to run on select and as soon
as you click it it will take you there
okay so now let's try it
and we can click on
canada
and it will take us to the wikipedia
page for the economy of canada
great we click on brazil
same thing
so if we unselect on brazil then it will
make our map highlighted normally again
we can also use this one to filter the
other visualizations
and so we could click use this filter
here and then when we click on france
it will filter these two other
visualizations to france
you can see that when we filter this
visualization
to a particular country
so if we look at
germany
germany wasn't green before on our map
but now it is that happens because our
scale has changed just for the ones
selected
so if we control click france and
germany and switzerland
and austria we now have a scale that
reflects only these countries and the
biggest is going to be the darkest green
or the highest gdp is the darkest green
and the lowest is the lightest pink
and there is our economy dashboard you
can see that we have some nulls on these
visualizations that occurs when we don't
have all of the data
for every point you can ignore those and
they won't show up on the final
visualization
when you publish it to server or you can
deal with those by clicking on them and
filtering that data out or showing that
data at the default position which is
showing the null values at zero our
final dashboard is going to be about the
ease of doing business in a country so
our first visualization is going to be a
bar chart which we will call days to
start
business
so how many days it takes to start a
business is important to know when
you're trying to start a business in a
country and also can be an indicator of
how easy it will be to do business in
that country so
let's make a bar chart that includes
every country and then we're going to
bring on days to start a business
and we will sort it smallest to biggest
and we have some days
or some countries that don't have
any days so let's filter out those
countries
and we're going to
filter it to only those that have a good
market
we're going to make a calculated field
we're going to define business friendly
market
well
we're going to define our market based
on how easy it is to start a business
and how many days it takes so if it
takes less than 25 days to start a
business we'll consider that a good
market and so we're going to do
if
the days to start a business is less
than or equal to 25
then
else if
space to start a business
is
greater than
25
then
business
might or might not
work
doing less than or equal to 25 or
greater than 25
allows us to be able to define these two
different markets so we'll hit
apply there
and we're going to filter it
just to a good market
and we're going to look at
just one year
look at 2012
our most recent year
and we're going to color it based on
region
and we can see
which regions tend to have
the shorter days to start a business
and we're going to
move on and build our next visualization
which is also a bar chart
which we will call ease of business
so we have this ease of business field
and we can bring on the country and we
can bring on ease of business
and we want to
make it a measure so the ease of
business is at this point looking at it
like it's
a string
and we can change that in our default
properties and convert it to a measure
or use it up here and change it to a
measure
when we try to change it to a measure
here it wants to treat it like a string
so it wants to take the minimum or the
maximum
but if we here convert it to a measure
then it also automatically made it a
count
so the first thing to do
would be to change the data type to a
number
and now
we can change it to a measure and
aggregate it so we could do
like the sum of ease of business
in our use case we're actually going to
do the
average of ease of business
and then we want to have the smallest on
the top we do have some that don't have
ease of business ratings
so we're going to filter that data out
and again we want the year to be 2012
but how we're going to do that is by
coming to this visualization
and by applying this particular year of
2012 so we'll do it on select workbooks
and select ease of business okay
and now this one also has
the year of 2012 there
and
we're going to
segment this by creating another header
we're going to call that
business
friendly
and we're going to say
that if the ease of business
is
so i guess this is a nice thing to know
so if if we start typing in what we want
to see then we can select it from a list
here but you can also interact outside
of this box so you could just grab ease
of business and drag it into the dialog
box here and that's really nice so we're
going to say if it is greater than or
equal to one
and less than or equal to
three
then
we're going to say it has the most
business
friendly
regulations
give us a little more room to look at
okay and this statement won't work
because it's saying and what is less
than or equal to three so you have to
have ease of business in both places
and then this should say then and not
the
great so now we're just getting an error
because we don't have an end
so if that's all we wanted to do then
that's what we would do but then we'll
just do another else if
and
it's already taken this
if statement goes through
one condition at a time so it's already
classified everything that's between
these two numbers and so
now we can just say
if ease of business
is
less than or equal to 10
then
we'll call it very
very business friendly regulations
and we'll keep going
else if ease of business is
less than or equal to 50
then
we're going to call it
moderate
and we're just going to say moderate
business
regulations
copy that for later use
less than equal to 150
then
strict
so
the reason that this doesn't grab
everything that is less than or equal to
150 is because
these sections 1 to 3 and then 3 or well
4 to 10
and then 11 to 50 have all been
classified up to this point so it's just
getting everything else
and we're going to
finally
say else everything else
is going to be called
not preferred
for
business
and see if we get any errors calculation
is valid let's see if this works as we
expect so we'll hit apply and we'll
bring business friendly onto our rows
and now it categorizes everything
based on what we said so
we want to define what order these go in
so we're going to click sort
and we want the
most business friendly at the top
then we want moderate then strict then
not preferred okay
so we have our top three that are the
most business friendly and then we've
got four through ten which are very then
we've got our moderate
our strict
and our
not preferred
so let's bring region again onto color
and we can see which regions are the
most business friendly
and we have our year of 2012 there
and now we're going to make this even
more useful by adding the business tax
rate onto the label
so that you can see that business
friendly
is like singapore but they have a pretty
high tax rate of 27 whereas if you get
down to some of these that are not
preferred
some of them have really low tax rates
so let's make sure that we're getting
okay the right tax rate
so
you can see that
27 is definitely not the highest tax
rate that we have for business
but you can also see that there are
places that have
even lower tax rates
like saudi arabia
and
we have
eight percent here
it looks like we don't ever go to
that second decimal place so let's
quickly
format this
oh business tax rate is also text
so if we could convert
our data type to
decimal
and then we will
format it
to be
a percentage
and we just need the one decimal place
okay
now let's make
some annotations so we could come and
click here
on this mark
and then we can annotate that mark which
will make this dialog box and it's
already filled in here
and so we could
use some of this information so i'm
going to copy that
and i'll put some hard returns there
so we're going to say
that this country
is the most
business friendly
but has a
business tax rate
of and let's grab the tax rate
and then we'll erase this
i will hit okay
and i've made a typo
so singapore is the most business friend
is not what i meant to say
so i can click edit
business friendly
but has a tax rate of and you can move
this around
draws the line to singapore which is the
mark
that we wanted to annotate so that is an
annotation on a mark if we wanted to
just make an annotation
for the area
then we could
point out that
more business friendly
countries
often have
high
business taxes
we can change that size make everything
fit
now we have this
second note
where our user can come in and see some
more information about what's being
presented here
great and now we're going to make one
more visualization
and it's going to be
about phone and internet usage
because you may want to know about the
phone and internet trends
when you're looking to start a business
so we're going to do this one over time
so it does not need to have that year
filter on it
and we're doing our continuous r axis
and we're going to
look at mobile phone usage so i double
clicked it shows mobile phone usage over
time
and we're going to change it to average
so that it's averaging it across the
countries
and then we're going to bring on
internet usage so we'll bring it on side
by side so we have two visualizations
and we're going to also make that
average
now we might not want these to share an
axis because they are measured a little
bit differently
and so we can make it a dual axis
but allow them to keep their independent
axes
or you can synchronize the axes
and see them at their
rates however
the uses is just a little bit
of a different measurement we can have
one of them be
a bar chart and the other one be a line
let's have this one be the bar chart
okay and then the line is in the front
you can also change which one's in the
front by
coming and clicking
on the axis itself
and you can click move marks to front
and then move that one to the front okay
and now it's made each of these wide and
there's like a star point and end point
on the axis for the bar and that comes
here under size
where they're all fixed
or you could have it be manual where we
can define the size of the bars so we're
going to make those bars like this
now we can see them going up over time
we can also change the width of the line
itself
make it thicker or thinner
and
we could change the colors here
so let's change it to
orange
since red might apply that it's bad in
some cultures
and now we can see our internet usage
and our phone usage over time and how
it's trending
and so this will all come together on
our new dashboard
which is about
ease of business
you can see that i have a sheet called
these as a business and a dashboard that
i've called ease of business but it
won't let you
create a dashboard with the same name
as your worksheet so
ease of business dashboard
let's have it fit the screen
and
we're going to bring on our
days to start business visual
our ease of business visual
and our
phone and internet visual
let's
put our legends at the top again
so we'll make
our horizontal
container
and we'll bring our region legend into
there and then our
measure names for internet versus
mobile phone
and we have a filter that already is
pre-applied to two of the visualizations
called year of year
and it's selected 2012 and if we select
2011
it's only changing this one it's
filtering out all the information for
this visualization and changing this one
to
2011.
so let's see why that's happening if we
go to this visualization
and click the go to
sheet we can see year of 2012 is here
let's click show filter
and if we change the filter
to 2011 okay it's not showing up here
and the only filter i can see that could
be removing it is this averages of
business
that is removing anything that is null
so if i pull that off you can see that
we don't seem to have any information
for 2011 for ease of business
and the more years i select
i'm not seeing any
ease of business information
so
we're going to want to set this
to
2012 only because that seems to be the
only information that is useful for this
visualization
so
let's go back until we're back to the
state
we were in
when we started
okay so here we are
now we're going to want to remove this
filter
and we're going to give it its own
filter
that only selects 2012
that is not connected to the other
filter
so now when we change your view it only
changes this visualization
sometimes that's useful to note
sometimes it's useful to put
let's do a single value
drop down sometimes it's useful to put
this
right next to the visualization it
affects
so if we could change it to floating
and just put it like
here
that makes it clear that
it's just changing this chart
so that people don't get confused
another thing that we can do that we
should do on all of our visualizations
is
change the titles so that they're more
business or user friendly
great
and
so we have our filter
and let's use this as a filter
and that way we can click on new zealand
and we can see it's a most business
friendly regulations and we can see its
internet
and phone usage over time
we can click on
a lot of different countries to see
those changes
you can see that
some countries have a steeper
change so some of them have
adopted phone and internet usage and
have stayed pretty similar whereas other
ones have only
really adopted it in the last couple of
years
also if we wanted to filter to just one
country we could do what we did before
and create a country filter
here's a another way to go to the sheet
you can click this down arrow and click
go to sheet or you can come over here
you can see that it's highlighting a
visualization over here or a sheet and
whatever sheet i click on is highlighted
over here
and there's this little pop-out arrow
here that also takes you to the sheet
now we can bring country
on
use them all
go back to our dashboard
we'll go to filters and select country
we'll make it a multiple value drop down
we're going to add the apply button and
now we're going to make it apply to all
the visualizations by
clicking apply to workbooks selected
worksheets all on dashboard okay
now we can see that if we just want to
look at afghanistan
okay
we can see
how many days it takes to start a
business there it's not preferred for
business and it's internet and phone
usage over time
and those are our
four dashboards so as a review we have
made
a dashboard on population
we made one about health
we made one that had to do with our
economy
and one that had to do with our ease of
doing business hello and welcome to our
presentation on tableau interview
questions today we'll be going over
answers to common interview questions
for tableau positions first question is
what are the data types supported in
tableau we have string date date and
time numerical boolean so true or false
and geographical in tableau you can tell
what kind of data type you have so when
you're on the data source tab you can
see that this is numerical and this is
string here we have a date we don't have
any date times here that would have the
little clock icon and we also have
geographical these are set by default
and you can change them by clicking on
the icon
and say we wanted row id to allow text
so we'll change it to string and you can
see the icon changes there the next
question has to do with how will you
understand dimensions and measures so a
key thing to remember is that dimensions
are qualitative and measures are
quantitative and if you can remember
those particular words it helps convey
what the interviewer is looking for so
dimensions are qualitative and you can
use them to categorize your data so for
example you can categorize your data by
what country it comes from and measures
are quantitative and can be aggregated
so you can do a sum of sales or you can
do the average profit did you know that
tableau automatically assigns each field
a data type and a role and that
automatically aggregates your measures
using sum but you can change what the
default aggregation is question three
what do you understand by discrete and
continuous in tableau so we have
discrete values and continuous values
discrete is represented as blue and
continuous is represented as green so
let's look in tableau when we go to our
worksheet
you can see that all the dimensions are
automatically blue
and all of the measures are green
however you can have a continuous
dimension and you can have a discrete
measure
so we have discrete dimensions which is
a blue dimension but also continuous
dimensions and data is a good example of
that let's take a look so we pull on
order date we right now have year
and it's making categories instead of a
continuous axis so it's making a finite
list there but we can change it to be
you can see now it's marked as
continuous here and it's green and we
change it to be an axis
instead of different categories it would
be a continuous axis
so you can also have discrete measures
which are blue measures and continuous
measures in the green so for example
let's say we had a visualization that
had
the region
and
sales
and profit
but instead of having an access for
profit maybe we just wanted to have a
number for the profit listed right next
to
the region and then we could have the
sales visualization so what we could do
is change it to a discrete
value and put it next to region and now
it's part of the labels
and that's an example of having a
discrete
measure
did you know that
continuous is infinite and discrete is
finite those are some key words that you
could use also to describe the
difference between continuous and
discrete and also just remember that
discrete is blue and continuous is green
the next question number four is what
are filters and name the different
filters in tableau so filters are a way
to restrict the data that allows you to
only see the data that you want to see
in your workbook or dashboard and there
are these different types of filters and
they also have a specific order so if
you can remember the different filters
that's helpful but also if you can
remember what order they apply in
that'll get you some definite bonus
points in your interview we have extract
filters that filter the data as it
extracts and it will affect how big your
extract is we also have data source
filters here which will filter the data
out of the data source however the
extract will still be the same size so
let's take a look at this handy
visualization
that tableau has on their website we
have the order of operations and in blue
we have our filters
so extracts is first and it filters down
your extract to just what you've
selected then we have data source
filters that will apply to the entire
data source so any visualization that
uses that data source will have these
filters we also have context filters
which are next which come before some of
these level of details that's the major
difference is that it applies before
some of these sets and conditional
values and then you will do dimensions
and then measures so any filters that
happen on dimensions happen before any
measure filters the last type of filter
we have is a table calculation filter
which happens after all of the rest of
them and basically just applies to
your visualization just the one
visualization question number five there
are three customer segments in the
superstore data set what percent of the
total profits is associated with the
corporate segment perfect so in some
tableau interviews you may be asked to
build a visualization for our examples
here we'll be using the superstore data
set and if you don't have access to the
superstore data set just comment below
and somebody on the simply learn team
will help you get access to that also
this is a fun opportunity to pause the
video and then you can work on this on
your own and then come back and see if
what you did was the right thing or how
we did it differently also you can
comment below on what your answer is and
we'll see if we can all get the right
thing
so let's build this
three customer segments in the super
store data set what percent of the total
profits total profits is associated with
corporate segment great so we're going
to bring on our segments and we have
consumer corporate and home office and
let's bring on our
total profit so i just did that by
double clicking and now it's just
bringing on the sum for each of those by
default but we want to figure out what
percent of the total each of these are
so we can change this to be
a table calculation we can click add
table calculation or we can do a quick
table calculation
and find percent of total so let's go
back to our question we wanted to know
the percent of total profits associated
with the corporate segment and the
corporate segment has 32.12
of the total profits and here's our
solution with
32.12 percent so did you get it right
comment below if you got that what are
the different joins in tableau give an
example
so in tableau
you can join your data so if we wanted
to look at orders and tie it to
people we could pull on people and it
will give you this visualization and you
can see all the different joints here
and we'll discuss those in just a second
you also have the opportunity to union
information which would be if we had
maybe two excel sheets that had orders
information
perhaps one of them had 2012 and one of
them had 2013
then you could take your orders and pull
it so you see that pop-up drag table to
union and that's another way to add more
data and so those are all worth
mentioning let's take a look at the
different kinds of joints
we have our inner join which will only
give you the values that have matches in
both tables
our left join that will give you all the
values in the left table and its matches
in the right table and then the right
join which will give you all the values
in the right table
and its matches in the left table
the outer join also known as a full
outer join will give you all the values
in the left and the right table
and then as we discuss the union you can
see it's represented by a more vertical
join and what it does is it adds more
rows all the rest of these are about
adding more columns but this will add
more rows
in the same columns that you had before
if you have the opportunity to draw out
the answer to this question and make
these venn diagrams it's a really
helpful way for you to explain your
point and it really portrays that you
know what you're talking about what is
the difference between a join and
blending in tableau so i just showed you
how to make a join here and we are
joining
an excel sheet
to another excel sheet all within the
same connection to that excel file so
when you're joining data we'll look over
here at the joining side that's when
you're bringing two or more tables
within the same data source and that's
how you join it and so um we're all
inside of a data source here which when
i go to sheet one just has one data
source here called orders whatever we
wanted to call it and that is all within
one data source however let's say we
already had two different data sources
in tableau and we wanted to bring
together two of them so in this case
it's an oracle table and we brought in
an oracle table and we made a data
source and then also an excel table that
had a second data source and you can
blend it together to get your combined
data set so the major difference what
you're going to really want to take away
from this is that blending is from two
separate tableau data sources and that
joining is all within one data source
and it ends up just being one data
source in the end in blending each data
source contains its own set of
dimensions and measures and when you
join it will combine it into one set of
dimensions and measures so let's go back
to our example here let's bring on
people it is automatically said we're
going to join it on region and we're
going to do an inner join that's fine by
me
and so we come here
and now we have just one
set of dimension and measures under
orders however if we were to add a
second data source which we will it'll
be an excel file and it will be based
off of this rank example
we'll open that up and now when we go to
sheet 1 we have two data sources
and if we were to blend this data
together we would still see two separate
sets of data only we would be able to
pull in from this set some information
and we'd pull in from this set some
other information so that's a visual
difference between blending and joining
question number eight is what is the
difference between a live and an extract
so first we'll talk about live and we'll
say that your dashboard is connected
live to a database and so a live
connection will query that database
every time you open up the dashboard or
visualization so that you're getting the
most recent information each time and
it's useful for if you need information
that's a little bit more real time
however it can be slower especially if
your queries are complicated with an
extract it will run the query beforehand
and store the information on tableau
server or on your local machine and so
that it's faster to get to however it is
not real-time information so if you had
a refresh of your extract that runs
every day in the morning and then during
the day somebody has made a change to
your database they won't see that change
on your dashboard until the next time
the refresh runs for your extract in
tableau
you can set
if you want the connection to be live or
extract when you first are making your
data source and this is a tableau
desktop in tableau
public you don't have that option did
you know that
the reason that extracts are faster is
because tableau doesn't need to access
the database each time it fills the
visualization and did you know that you
can set up a refresh schedule on tableau
server in order to be able to see your
extracted data update
question 9 what is a calculated field
and how will you create one so if we
look at our data set here
we have the opportunity to see the
difference between order date and ship
date so to create a calculated field you
click create calculated field with this
drop down arrow at the top or you can
right click in white space
create calculated field
then you give it a name
and we're going to call it
shipping delay and we are going to do
[Music]
a date diff so if you don't see this
dialog box here you can click this arrow
to see that
our date part is day the start date is
order date and the end date is ship date
so to remember how to create a
calculated field it's by clicking this
down arrow and clicking create
calculated field
and then writing your
query here
and a calculated field is an additional
field made up using the data that you
already have so
we've made a new field here and it has
the equal sign at the beginning that
might be worth mentioning how to tell if
it's a calculated field or if it was an
original field and then we can bring a
shipping delay
here and we can see the number of days
that it took between the order date and
the ship date we could also
duplicate a calculated field so now we
have shipping delay copy
and we're going to call this
average shipping delay
and we're going to encapsulate it
inside an average function
and now if we take off the order id the
order date and the ship date
it's automatically summing up those days
but we can bring on our average shipping
delay
and you can see on average how many days
it took
and let's change
our number here to
include decimal places
so a calculated field is a new field
made from existing data
it can be used to create more robust
visualizations and it does not affect
the original data set for example we
made our average delay function here
using data from our original data set
question 10 how can you display top five
and last five sales in the same view
you can show top five and last five
sales for a same dimension by creating a
set
so let's take a look at doing that here
we have
our customers so let's bring on customer
name
and we're going to do it based on profit
so now that we've done it on profit we
can see these are our top five profit
and i've sorted it by profit and
here's our bottom five
and we can create a set by coming and
clicking on the dimension that we want
the set to be based on we'll right click
there
and we will
come to create and click set
we're going to call this top customers
top by field top five
five sum of profit and now we have a set
it makes a set section here
now we're going to make a second set
off of customer name
create set
bottom customers
bottom
5 by
sum of profit we'll hit ok and now we're
going to combine these two sets so i'm
going to control click and then we have
both of them selected and we're going to
click create combined set
top and bottom
customers
and we're going to have it include all
members of both sets
and now we can pull top and bottom
customers onto filters and you can see
our top five and our bottom five so if
we
control drag profit onto color
then it's colored by that as well so key
thing to remember is that you can use it
sets to create to show both the top and
the bottom in the same visualization and
that you can combine those sets
is there a difference between sets and
groups in tableau the answer to this is
yes
you can describe a group as being
simpler and using only one dimension to
determine the group whereas a set can be
more complex so you could say sets are
more complex and you can use conditions
to create the sets and you can also use
multiple dimensions and measures to
create the sets
for example here
we create a group of subcategory so we
grab all of these things together and
can group it and that will be
we'll have copiers and envelopes and
then we'll have one group
of all of these together
over here you could create a set
that looks at sales and profits
to create its set so the best way i can
describe this is by looking at what we
did here and so we were able to use
dynamic
filtering here to create our sets
and where we'll look at the top five or
the bottom five and let's do the same
thing we did there but use a group so
for a group we could see that these
we've sorted it and we can say
one two three
four five this is the top five so we
could create
a group that's this paper clip here and
now we have a group of the top five and
it's added that group it makes a new
group customer name group and it put it
on the color for us now let's go to the
bottom and we're going to go one two
three four five and we'll create
our group
so now we have a top five group at
bottom five group so let's name them
that and we'll do that by clicking edit
alias
top customers
okay and we'll come here and we'll
rename that
bottom
customers
okay we'll put our top customers on top
and then let's hide all the others so
we'll click exclude there and now we
have a similar visualization as we had
before for our
sets top bottom however a key difference
here is that we had to go through and
select the top five and the bottom five
so let's say that
maybe
cindy or let's say henry goldwyn has
suddenly
had much more positive profit associated
with them if that changes he's going to
still stay in our group this group is
just using these customer names to
determine who's in the group
so the group is henry sherrell luke
grant and cindy no matter if their data
changes so say tomorrow all this data is
different it's still going to put these
people into the group however the sets
as you saw before is based off of the
profit the sum of profit and who has the
top five and who has the bottom five if
raymond suddenly has a lot less profit
and falls out of the group then
the groups won't pick it up but the sets
will so that's one thing to remember is
that it could be based on conditions and
then you saw how we took two sets and
put them together into our combined
group you could also have a set that is
based off of two different dimensions
or two different measures and that's how
you could put those two sets together
and get dynamic sets
so the major differences as we saw is
that a group is just based off of one
dimension
and a set can have conditions and be
based on off of other dimensions
also you need to know that groups cannot
be used in calculated fields but sets
can
question 12
what is a parameter in tableau and give
an example
a parameter is a dynamic value that a
customer could select
and you can use it to replace constant
values in calculations filters and
reference lines so for example here we
determined we wanted bottom five and top
five customers but let's give them some
options so we'll create a parameter
and we'll call it select
number of
top
bottom
customers
and we're going to
[Music]
let it be a range
with a minimum of 5
and a maximum of
20
and a step size of five so we'll let
them go five at a time
okay
now if we click show parameter control
we can see our parameter control and you
can do 5 10 15 or 20. but since it's not
in any of our calculated fields or sets
or filters then it's not making any
difference so let's put it inside of
these
we'll edit our set and instead of top or
bottom five
we'll click bottom select number of top
bottom customers so now it's taking our
parameter and inserting it in
to our set there we'll do the same thing
with top customers
okay and now right now we see top five
bottom five if we change it now we see
top ten bottom ten fifteen and there's
our twenty
so it replaces a constant value and
allows the end user to select the value
question 13 what is the difference
between tree maps and heat maps
so let's first talk about what each of
these are
heat maps compare categories using size
and color i think the biggest thing
about heat maps is the color size is
somewhat optional so let's build this
visualization quickly
so
we have region
category
and subcategory
and we're making a heat map so
we want to bring profit onto color
and you can see we've got hotter and
colder in this case
for a heat map we might want to change
so in this case what it's doing is
hotter is negative but we could reverse
that and then hotter is positive and so
hotter maybe means this is where more
activity is
we can also double click on profit
we can also bring profit onto label
and we'll change this to
square and now it's marked at what
everything is so a heat map
will use color to draw your eye to the
places where there's heat or maybe
activity we could also use size in this
case so it's not just defined by color
necessarily maybe we want the size to be
defined by sales so we get things that
are bigger but they're blue which means
that they are bigger in sales but their
profit is negative and it draws your
eyes to
technology so machines in the south are
doing a lot of sales but they're not
having positive profit necessarily
also you can see some things that have
darker colors
but are smaller so high profit but not a
lot of sales so that is a heat map a
tree map is used to represent
hierarchical data now hierarchy is the
term you need to remember when you're
talking about the difference between a
tree map and a heat map
in the heat map none of these boxes have
to do with the hierarchy with each other
whereas with a tree map you can see that
this box has a thick white line between
it and the other ones and that means
that that section
are all connected so these are all
technology
and the bigger this section is that
means the bigger the let's see size is
based off of profit so this bigger
section means that technology has more
profit than furniture so let's build
this one when i build tree maps i like
to use our show me tool so here's tree
map and it says one or more dimensions
or one and one to two measures so we're
going to grab category and we're going
to control click subcategory and we're
going to control click profit and
sales and we'll click on our tree map
perfect and so the darker the color
that means the more sales there is and
that's pretty similar to our
heat map over here so the color
indicated
in this case it was profit so the color
indicates the difference and the size
indicates the difference and that's true
over here the color indicates a
difference and the size indicates a
difference however there is a hierarchy
to it over here you can see that there
is um hierarchies because we have
furniture and then that puts that all
together under furniture
and then here's the subcategories
however if you were trying to compare
furniture to office supplies it's really
difficult to tell which one has more
sales but if we go over to sheet 7 that
has our tree map on it you can see
really quickly that office supplies has
much more sales
than furniture in this case office
supplies has much more profit than
furniture the biggest difference is that
tree maps have the hierarchy question
number 14 what is the difference between
twbx
and twb so these are all
tableau file formats and the twbx
contains all of the unnecessary
information to build the visualization
so it's called a packaged workbook and
it compresses it all together however
the twb just contains instructions about
how to interact with the data source so
when it's building a visualization
tableau will look at the data source and
then build the visualization with an
extract it contains all of the
information that you need so all the
data is wrapped up inside of there and
there's no connection that has to be
made between tableau and the data source
because it's all right inside whereas
with the twb it has to connect to the
data source or else it doesn't have the
data to build the visualizations it just
knows it has the instructions of what to
do with that data so the biggest
difference is twbx
has the data inside of it whereas a twb
only has the instructions question 15
explain the difference between tableau
worksheet dashboard story and workbook
perfect here's a breakdown and
explanation of each of those and in
tableau this entire thing that we've
been looking at all these sheets
is a workbook
however this sheet 7 is just one
worksheet all of them together is a
workbook and sheet 7 is a worksheet the
big difference between a worksheet and a
dashboard is that the worksheet is just
one
visualization and so it is only one set
of columns and rows here and a dashboard
could contain multiple visualizations so
if we wanted to see our heat map and our
tree map
on the same page that would be a
dashboard and then a story
is somewhat similar
to a presentation mode and so you can
have different pages and so we could say
here is our
heat map and then we could make another
page
and look at our
tree map and then look at our heat map
and then we could duplicate that page
and we could say let's focus on
furniture
so we're going to highlight furniture
and then so if we were to go through
these one at a time
we would say here's your tree map and
then we would look at information there
and we would say here's our heat map and
then the next screen will say let's
focus on furniture and you can see that
it highlighted furniture for me when i
went to the next scene so a story
can show you things one at a time it's
like a presentation mode so the
differences are the workbook contains
the sheets and the dashboards of the
stories
the worksheet is a single view
dashboard is multiple views and a story
is a sequence a sequence is a good key
word to remember when you're describing
a story and did you know
that the only place that you can access
the dimensions and the measures and
custom fields we've made is on a
worksheet so when you're looking at a
dashboard
so on a worksheet we see dimensions and
measures when you're looking at a
dashboard you no longer see dimensions
and measures what you do see are all of
the worksheets similarly when you look
at a story you no longer see
any dimensions and measures but you do
see all the worksheets and the
dashboards question 16 what do you
understand by blended axis with a
blended axis you can use
two measures that share an axis and that
means they necessarily have the same
scale so let's build something with a
blended axis
so we can make a visualization
that looks at
sales
over time
we'll bring on order date
and
let's just
do order date by
month there we go
so we can see sales over time and say we
wanted to also see profit
this is two visualizations that have two
different axes but if we wanted them to
have the same axes
and just the same marks card you see how
i made two different marks cards we
could bring on
measure values
and take off all the measures that we
don't want
we just want
when we take them off here it's creating
this filter here for measure names
and let's take off these two extra
visualizations and now we have a
visualization that has a blended axes
for sales over time and profit over time
and you can see that they necessarily
have the same axes there is no second
axes
what is the use of a dual axis and how
do you create one perfect so a dual axis
allows you to compare measures and you
can have two different scales so if we
had this same visualization that same
information that we wanted to see with
again profit
and sales
over time
we'll do
okay great and we wanted them to have
the same axes we could right click on
the second pill
of the measures
and click dual axis and now you can see
that they do not
share the same axis and you can see
profit is much higher here right there
and so the use of this would be
sometimes you need things to have
different axes
if you come here and you click
synchronize axes you end up getting a
pretty similar visualization but you do
get two separate marks cards
so a key thing to bring up if you are
asked the difference between a blended
axis and a dual axis chart
is
one that the blended axis uses the same
scale and a dual axis could have two
different scales and two a dual axis has
two marks cards so let's say we wanted
our profit
to not be a line chart but to be a bar
chart that gives you that option when
you go to the blended axis we only have
one mark's card so we change it to bar
everything is bar
but back over here we change it to
circles and we see the circles so if we
wanted to show sales by year and profit
ratio by year in the same view that's
where two different scales could be
handy let's build that visualization
so we'll make a new chart
and we'll bring on sales
and
profit ratio
over time
that is profit i still did profit so
i'll drag profit ratio right over top of
profit there we go and you can see that
they can't use the same scale because
this is a percentage and so
if we had them on a blended axis 20
percent is really 0.2 and it would just
be so tiny
but if we wanted them on the same area
to act to apply to the same space here
we could dual access it that you can
still see useful information there but
otherwise this would just be in such a
tiny tiny space
so our profit ratio would just show up
right here almost like a straight line
question 18 what will the following
function return
left three comma tableau here's the
question again and here are the
potential answers tab
or eau error or none of the above so
just take a moment and see if you can
answer this question correctly go ahead
and pause the video and if you get the
answer you can comment below and then we
will discuss
we've taken some time to
answer this question and let's go ahead
and see what the answer is the answer is
it will return an error that's because
the syntax for a left is that the string
must go first first you say left then
you put the string and then you put the
number so let's talk about what left
does it returns a specific number of
characters from the left and if you had
done it correctly the left is this side
so if you had done the string first and
you said you want three the result would
be t a b there's also one called right
and that would come from the other end
and go eau so that's where these answers
came from question 19 how do you handle
null and other special values tableau is
unable to plot null values or zeros or
negative values on a logarithmic axis
and so it will display an indicator in
the lower right corner which looks like
this
telling you that is unable to draw those
two points
so when you click on the indicator you
can choose from the following first you
can choose to filter the data which will
exclude the null values from the
visualization or you can click show data
at the default position so we'll look at
both of these
so you click on your indicator and it
will say what do you want to do with
these two values if we click filter the
data then you can see that it has
filtered those that blank space and
drawn a line connecting
those dates in between even though there
is no point for the 29th or the 30th it
goes straight from the 28th to the 31st
so what's happening on our visualization
is it's adding this filter if we press
the back button we see that filter
disappears if we come down and select
filter the data it adds a filter here
that then
only includes non-null values
so those are all removed from our
visualization and up to this point you
can see that we have one point per day
the 21st the 22nd the 23rd 24th but then
when we get to the 28th we don't have a
29th or 30th and it just draws that line
to the 31st
assuming
that during that time period
what we want is a straight line now the
other option would be
we could also make the assumption that
whenever there is a null value that
actually means zero sales have happened
during that time so that's when you
would click show data at default
position
and now it draws those two points
at the zero line
and when you hover it still shows sales
null
so then when you hover here you can see
the actual amount for sales during that
time
so if a null in your data means zero
then show a default position is good for
you and if it doesn't necessarily mean
zero
then you can
filter the data or you can leave it
disconnected like this
question 20 find the top product
subcategories by sales within each
delivery method which subcategory is
ranked number two for first class ship
mode if you'd like to pause the video
and work on this on your own and then
see if
what you did matches what we did then
you're welcome to now at this time and
comment below what your answer is
okay
so we want to know by subcategory
and by ship mode
which
subcategory ranks the highest for each
ship mode so in sales so if we take
sales onto the visualization we can see
that by the ship mode
it's already split up and we could see
that
maybe this one for standard class it
would be chairs you can kind of look
through and kind of oh it's not chairs
chairs isn't number one because we have
this one it's phones so to make it
easier we're going to
change some of sales to a rank table
calculation so we're going to come here
and click add table calculation
and we're going to change the
calculation type to rank
and it's going to rank them
in order
of sales
so but we right now we can see that it's
highlighting that's called calculation
assistance helping us understand
how it's ranking us so if i and select
calculation assistance then it gets rid
of it but you can see right now it's
ranking it
across the table so it says accessories
has most sales in standard class then
second class then first class then same
day
and that's not what we want to see we
want to see it up and down
we want to see for first class which
subcategory has the highest sales and
second highest sales so let's turn back
on our calculation assistance and we're
going to click table down
you can see now it's going up and down
within first class what are all the
subcategories ranked so that's what we
want now as soon as you click things in
the table calculation it applies it over
here so you don't have an ok button
so you can just close that out
and you can see now we have a rank up
and down
for the subcategory so back to the
question was which subcategory is ranked
second for first class ship mode here's
first class let's find number two it's
chairs
question number 21 find the customer
with the lowest overall profit what is
his slash her profit ratio let's go
ahead and build this visualization
customer profit
and we're going to
bring all of our customers on
and then we're going to bring on profit
let's do it as a visualization so i'll
bring it on to columns
and then let's sort smallest to biggest
so cindy stewart
is the one who has our lowest profit
and now to figure out her profit ratio
we need to make a calculated field which
i've already made here
so in this calculated field we take the
sum of profit and divided by the sum of
sales we do this
so that it will sum up all of the profit
per row so for cindy we want to take all
of her profit
over all of her transactions and divide
it by all of her sales instead of doing
it row by row profit divided by sales
profit divided by sales and then summing
that up at the end so
we'll take our profit ratio and put it
on the label
and we can see
what her profit ratio is and since it's
a ratio here i have it in a percent
if you don't have your profit ratio set
up as a percent it will look like this
negative 1.65 question number 22
what is the rank function in tableau we
got a look at the rank function earlier
when we figured out our top product
subcategories by sales and what was
ranked number two so
i'm sure you're familiar with what
ranking is which is assigning something
a position like first place or second
place usually within a category and
usually based on a measure so
tableau is able to rank in several
different ways where you can do
rank or rank dense rake modified or rank
unique and we'll take a look at these
individualization here and talk about
the difference but if you are asked
about
the rank function in tableau it's worth
bringing up that there are several
different ways to rank and going into a
little bit of detail on those different
ways will be helpful for you so
let's
build off of this rank example instead
so we're going to bring on our store and
we've got store a b c d and e
and then we'll bring on our sales
and store a had ten dollars and e had
forty dollars
so
now let's
create a calculated field we're going to
call it rank
we're going to do a rank calculated
field
based on sales
we're going to do a rank calculated
field based on sum of sales
perfect
okay
we'll double click on rank and we can
see first place is the one who had the
most sales and fifth place is the one
with the least sales now we had a tie
here at 20 and it gave them both third
place and then it skipped fourth place
and went to fifth place and that's how
the basic rank function works
so if we duplicate it
and we edit our copy
and we're going to make this one
rank dense
you know what let's do rank modified
second
okay
and we bring on rank modified
let's have this happen in order so sum
of sales then rank then rank modified
now you can see
it's similar to rank first second but
then it skips third and goes to fourth
and then fifth so over here it gave them
buyer number when there was a tie and
over here it gave them the lower number
when there was a tie
so if you could remember that
rank gives them the higher number and
rank modified gives them the lower
number that will be helpful
for your interview
now we're going to take a look at rank
dense
rank dense apply
and rank dense doesn't skip a number so
it goes one two three four and it
condenses
the ranking
without any skipping any numbers
and now let's
do our last one
which is going to be
rank unique
okay
and with rank unique it refuses to give
to
the same rank
and how it determines when there is a
tie
is it will look at the dimension
that's in the visualization and do
whichever one comes first in ascii so it
goes one two and these are a tie and
since capital b comes before
lowercase c
then it's doing b first then c
then a
so in your interview it would be really
impressive to talk about the different
versions of ranks and how they all work
question 23 how can you embed a web page
in a dashboard so we're just going to
build this and then explain it so i have
here my map by sales and we're going to
build a dashboard
we'll bring on first we'll change our
layout so i can fill up the screen
then let's bring on my map
and i've added the state name and the
sales on the map here
for
an embedded web page you can grab it
from the objects section the web page
and then you could put a url right
inside of here
and then that will embed that page
underneath
so if we wanted to do wikipedia or
something we can hit ok and it will take
you to wikipedia
but what we're going to do is make this
page dynamic based on what state you
select it'll look up that wikipedia page
for that state so you could maybe look
at some population data
we'll close that and we'll try again
we're going to bring on our web page
it's going to ask for a url but we're
just going to hit ok and not provide it
with a url
and then we'll use this dashboard action
and create a url action
that then contains our url
with our state
appended at the end which is how
wikipedia formats their url so we'll hit
okay
oh i forgot one more thing let's do it
on select instead of on menu so whenever
we select something it will run this
okay
okay and now when we select texas
it brings up the texas wikipedia page
when we select nebraska
it'll change
so the major points to know on how to
embed a web page is you bring it in from
the objects section and then if they ask
how to make a dynamic you use dashboard
actions
and a url action
question 24 design a view to show
region-wide profit and sales
so one way you could do this is by
bringing on region and then bringing on
profit
and
sales
and that's a pretty simple view of
profit and sales by region however
one thing that interviewers may be
looking for when asking a question about
region
is your mapping capabilities in tableau
so
what we could do
is
region is not a geographic location so
it takes a little bit of creativity but
if you bring on state by double clicking
it and it maps out the states
you can
make it a map here and it fills it in
and then you can bring region onto color
and that splits it up by region
and then if you bring on profit
and sales on the labels
and let's also bring on the state onto
labels
and then you can look at your profit and
sales inside of their regions inside of
their states
and so um
that is another view where you could
look at
profit and sales by region and it's a
little bit more
takes advantage of some of the mapping
capabilities in tableau it may be what
your interviewer is looking for so you
could discuss multiple ways to look at
it but here is one way that we could
recommend it question 25 how can you
optimize the performance of a dashboard
there are multiple ways to optimize the
performance of the dashboard some of the
things that you might mention is that
you could exclude any fields you're not
using from your visualization just keep
them off or you can use extract filters
and if you recall extract filters will
remove out rows of data from the extract
and so only focus on the data that you
need another thing you can do is try and
limit the amount of filters that you use
and when you do use filters avoid using
quick filters and you can use action
filters and parameter filters instead
filters cause your queries in the
database to be a little bit more complex
and can keep
them from running as efficiently as they
could use min and max instead of average
because average functions require more
processing time than min max also you
can try to use boolean and numerical
calculations because computers do better
with integers and booleans than they do
with strings
so quick things to remember is keep your
data simple use fewer filters and when
you do use filters use parameters or
actions avoid using average use min and
max and avoid using strings by using
booleans and numerical calculations
question 26 which visualization will be
used in the given scenarios here we have
three scenarios of opportunities that
you might want to visualize
and there is no perfectly exact answer
for these but there are some
visualizations that tend better for
certain types of data however there
sometimes could be
different ways to visualize it and it
doesn't mean that these are the very
best ways however if you want to take a
moment go ahead and pause the video and
go through and figure out what your
three answers are and comment below and
we can discuss what we think the best
ways are so first we want to show
aggregated sales totals across a range
of product categories and subcategories
we want to show the duration of events
or activities and we want to show
quarter wise profit growth so to show
aggregated sales totals across a range
of products subcategories and categories
you could use a tree map the reason we
bring up a tree map here is that they
are known for allowing you to show a
visualization
using hierarchies so let's take a look
at that we're going to show aggregated
sales totals across a range of product
categories and subcategories so if we
come here and make a sheet
and we want to see
sales across control click
category and subcategory and then we
click a tree map
what happens
it's showing
it based on size and color
and so it shows the size the bigger the
size the more sales and the darker the
color the more sales and the reason we
choose a tree map over just a normal
heat map is that
it makes a category here so we can
compare this box that has all the
technology in it see how all these are
technology to this box that has all of
the office supplies and you can quickly
see the technology
has more than office supplies but you
can also see that phones has more than
art
and it breaks it up as a hierarchy and
breaks it up based on your sum of sales
and question two is show duration or
events a duration of events or
activities and you would use a gantt
chart gun charts are used to show
duration
and each of these lines
is a duration so it's like it's got a
start date and end date basically and it
shows you how long everything takes and
the last one is to show
profit growth and you can use a
waterfall chart and that looks like
this where you can see how the profit
changes across every period and if it's
going up or down and each one of these
show you how much up or how much down
they go but as we said there are
potentially other answers to this
question so
if you have any questions about why we
didn't say this chart or that chart go
ahead and comment below and we can start
a discussion question 27 what would you
do if some countries or provinces or any
geographical entity is missing and
displaying a null when you use map view
so when you start to map the
geographical fields that you have
sometimes tableau is unable to map them
because their locations are unknown or
ambiguous meaning a lot of states have a
city called springfield and it won't
know where to draw that city so for
example
let's look at
here so we've taken city as our detail
and it's drawn a lot of cities however
it's got a lot of unknown values here so
if this question comes up you've got to
remember these three things you can edit
locations filter the data or show data
at default position
edit locations allows you to correct the
locations
by putting in their unique names i'll
show you an example of this filter the
data means just keep them off of the
view and show data default position
means show it at 0 zero on the map
so edit locations
here we can say here's all of these
cities that seem to exist
in multiple locations and we could say
well we know what state they're in as
well and that should help you answer the
question so you could choose a field
that will define the state so here we're
saying the state is from the state field
and we hit ok
and then they can draw the rest of those
cities
sometimes you want to keep them off
perhaps maybe they spelled city names
wrong and you just want to exclude those
and the last one is show data default
position
which is zero zero
28 what is a level of detail expression
a level of detail expression or an lod
expression is maybe the way they will
present it to you and lod stands for
level of detail so obviously it helps
you get to the level of detail that you
want in your visualization but it also
is used to run complex queries at the
data source level instead of all in the
tableau interface
so we're going to take a look at an
example here which is adding a dimension
to an already
calculated aggregate field in our case
we're going to exclude a dimension from
a calculated field so
here we have
a visualization that i built and right
now it's just looking at sales by
category and subcategory but say we
wanted to look at the total sales for
furniture
and not break it up by the subcategory
so if we take off subcategory
then we get the total sales for
furniture but if we want a side by side
and so that you could see the total
sales for furniture and you can see
it broken up by subcategory you can use
a level of detail calculation
this i already made the field for it
i've called it exclude subcategory so
that's right here
right now it just contains sales
but we're going to use the level of
detail calculation exclude
and we're going to tell it what to
exclude which is sub category and then
we're going to do
sum of sales so that it will sum it up
for us
and once i apply these changes it should
change it here and our labels
perfect so now we can see that it's
ignoring the fact that this is chairs
and this is table so this is bookcases
it's just doing the total for furniture
and just ignoring these because we told
it to exclude so level of detail helps
you to be able to define the level that
you want to in your visualization
regardless of what else exists on your
visualization
it also moves some of the logic from
inside of tableau to the actual database
and there are three level of detail
calculations this will be an important
thing to bring up in interviews they
might give you brownie points when you
can remember all three of the level of
detail calculations which are
we looked at exclude
but we have
exclude
include
and
fixed
so include excluder pretty easy to
remember and just always remember fixed
as well question 29 how do you calculate
daily profit measure using level of
detail here's another opportunity for
you to pause the video and take a look
at calculating a daily profit measure
using level of detail we are going to
get started
profitable level of detail so we want to
have a daily profit measure
and i already made a place for it profit
per day
and we want to look at the profit for a
day regardless
of what else is on the visualization so
we're going to use a fixed
instead of an include or an exclude
which will only take into account
whatever you put in for include or
exclude fixed will take into account
everything it will ignore everything
else on the visualization and only look
at what's in your list here so we're
going to fix it by day
and you have to put a colon
and we're going to do a sum of profit
for each of those days
and close it off so now we have our
profit per day and we'll hit okay and
now we're going to make a kpi
which for our purposes if profit for a
day is greater than 2000
then that day is highly profitable if
it's less than zero then it's
unprofitable otherwise it is profitable
so we're going to go if
our profit per day
is greater than 2000
then
we're gonna call it highly profitable
elsif
we're gonna do less than or equal to
zero
then
profitable
else
otherwise it is profitable
you always have to end with an end
great
okay
so now we're going to make
some visualizations and it's going to
look at it by year
now it all fits in one view we um
can rotate these labels to make it
easier to see and we're going to bring
on
order id
but now it's showing like a lot of
orders and so we actually want it to be
used as a measure and we're going to do
account distinct
great so now we can see how many orders
we're on each day
and so that's helpful for us to see how
many orders are on this day each day but
we want to see
what the orders on each day that are
highly profitable versus unprofitable
versus just profitable so we're going to
use
our level of detail
and break it up in a different section
so we have highly profitable profitable
and unprofitable let's also bring this
on to our color
highly profitable profitable and
profitable and now we can see
that the profitable ones are going up
unprofitable ones seem to be going down
in 2015 and that's nice but they are
going up and highly profitable is not
very many
oh in this case we did area charts
instead of just line charts to make that
change you change it from automatic to
area and that helps you see some of that
spatially as well comment below if you
were able to make this visualization on
your own
question 30. how can you schedule a
workbook in tableau after publishing it
so when you publish a workbook in
tableau if you've used an extract you're
going to need to refresh that extract so
in tableau when you create a tableau
data source and it's an extract version
of the data source it will no longer
update if the data from your database
updates so somebody's made some changes
to your database or your excel file and
you want to see that in your tableau
visualization well you're not going to
see it but you can see it if you make a
refresh so you do that on tableau server
and you can remember that you have to
get all the way to your data source so
you can go to your data sources or to
your workbooks
and then you look at the data source on
your workbook and you go actions extract
refresh and then you select schedule a
refresh so that looks like this you can
press these three dots next to it and
click refresh extracts or you can go to
actions and then here you click schedule
a refresh instead of refresh now
and then often times in tableau you'll
have several different options you can
choose daily at 7am or every four hours
if an interviewer is asking you about
how to schedule a refresh it might be
worthwhile bringing up the fact that you
only need to schedule a refresh if you
are
using an extract on your data source and
then that will help them know that you
know the difference between live and
extracts if they didn't ever ask that
question
with that we have come to the end of
this video on the tableau crash course i
hope it was useful and informative if
you liked it then please subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon to stay updated with all the latest
trending technologies in case you have
any queries related to this video then
please put it in the comments section
our team will help you address your
queries thank you for watching the video
stay safe and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here